Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur Ausgabe 58 unserer Gesprächsreihe
über Wissenschaft und alles, was die Wissenschaft tangiert.
Und heute hat es mich mal in den hohen Norden verschlagen.
Konkret nach Rostock und noch ein wenig konkreter hier in den Hafenbereich,
und zwar zum Thün-Institut für Ostseefischerei.
Und begrüße meinen Gesprächspartner für heute, nämlich Christopher Zimmermann, schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Herr Zimmermann, Sie sind der Leiter des Thün-Instituts.
Wie lange gibt es das schon?
Das Thün-Institut als Gesamtorganisation gibt es seit 2008.
Und es wurde gegründet als Zusammenschluss aus Teilen der alten Forschungsanstalt für Landwirtschaft in Braunschweig.
Da sitzt auch unsere Zentrale nach wie vor.
Der Bundesforschungsanstalt für Forst und Holz in Hamburg-Bergedorf
und der Bundesforschungsanstalt für Fischerei mit einer Reihe von Fachinstituten.
Und wir waren vorher ein Fachinstitut der Bundesforschungsanstalt für Fischerei.
Und sind jetzt eben ein Fachinstitut des großen Thün-Instituts, das aus 14 Fachinstituten besteht.
Wer ist jetzt der eigentliche Träger?
Finanziert wird das Ganze vom Bundeslandwirtschaftsministerium.
Wir sind eine Ressortforschungseinrichtung, also eine Forschungseinrichtung,
die dem BML, also dem Ernährungs- und Landwirtschaftsministerium unterstellt ist
und unserer Grundfinanzierung kommt aus der Bundesregierung.
Die Grundfinanzierung, aber das ist nicht die einzige Quelle?
Das ist nicht die einzige Quelle, wir haben inzwischen, also in der Fischerei wenigstens,
ungefähr 40-50% drittmittelfinanzierte oder Drittmittelfinanzierung.
Also vor allen Dingen Stellen kommen mit so einem ganz großen Anteil aus dem europäischen Haushalt.
Ach so, also jetzt nicht von … sind jetzt keine Forschungsaufträge von Firmen oder so,
wie man das so aus der normalen Universitätsbranche kennt?
Ganz wenig Firmen, wir haben tatsächlich eine Mitarbeiterin,
die aus Firmengeldern, also vor allen Dingen aus Verbandsgeldern finanziert wird,
aber im Wesentlichen ist es genau wie bei Universitäten.
Wir haben Projekte des BMBF, des Bundesforschungsministeriums.
Wir haben sehr wenig DFG-Projekte, weil die DFG die Ressortforschung nicht besonders gerne finanziert.
Aber unser größter Batzen sind eben tatsächlich EU-Forschungsmittel,
und das können einerseits reine Forschungsmittel sein,
also im Horizon2020-Programm ausgegebene Mittel.
Das sind dann in der Regel so 3 Millionen Euro internationale Verbundprojekte.
Wir haben aber auch Zugriff zu den sogenannten EMFF-Mitteln,
zu den Mitteln des europäischen maritimen und Fischereifond.
Und über diesen Fond zahlt die europäische Union vor allen Dingen die Datenerhebung aus der Fischerei.
Das haben die irgendwann gegründet, 2002 war das glaube ich,
um sicherzustellen, dass die Nationen nicht einfach nur auf Good Will Daten sammeln aus der Fischerei
und über die Fischbestände im Meer, sondern dass das wirklich verstetigt wird
und verlässlich erhoben wird, auch nach den gleichen Standards.
Und ich habe hier am Institut inzwischen glaube ich 15 Mitarbeiter,
die dauerhaft aus EMFF, also aus den europäischen Mitteln bezahlt werden.
Bevor wir vielleicht zu den Themen des Instituts und auch Ihren Themen kommen,
würde mich natürlich mal interessieren, wie so Ihr eigener Werdegang eigentlich gewesen ist.
Wie kommt man denn, was war das denn für ein Verlauf?
Ja das war eigentlich ein ungeplanter Verlauf.
Ich habe in Kiel schon Abitur gemacht und habe mich für Biologie und für Grafik interessiert.
Bin an der Grafikhochschule nicht genommen worden oder wenigstens nicht sofort.
Habe dann angefangen, nach dem Zivildienst Biologie zu studieren
und gleich das erste Semester war sehr faszinierend, hatte viel mit zeichnen zu tun
und Schnippelkurs haben wir das genannt, also mit Tieren einfach und die sezieren
und zu lernen, wie das funktioniert und so bin ich am Ende …
Aber wie kommt man denn von Grafik zu Biologie?
Ja das waren so meine beiden Leidenschaften.
Ich habe schon Kunstleistungskurs und Biologieleistungskurs gemacht
und konnte mich immer nicht recht entscheiden.
Und als ich mich dann entschieden hatte, bin ich bei dieser Grafikerschule von 300 Bewerbungen unter die letzten 20 gekommen,
aber es wurden nur 12 genommen.
Und dann haben die mich beruhigt und gesagt, versuche es mal nächstes Jahr nochmal,
da gibt es dann Wartezeiten.
Und in dieser Wartezeit habe ich angefangen Biologie zu studieren.
Und das hat so viel Spaß gemacht, dass ich gesagt habe, das mache ich jetzt erst mal weiter.
Bin dann auch dabei geblieben und dann konnte man wenigstens damals in Kiel nicht im Ernst Biologie studieren,
ohne in die Meeresforschung reinzugucken.
Und auch das war wieder ausgesprochen spannend.
Und am Ende bin ich über Umwege, weil ich einfach immer nur das gemacht habe,
wofür ich gebrannt habe, was mir wirklich Spaß gemacht hat, in der Polarforschung gelandet.
Bin drei Monate mit Polarstern in die Antarktis gefahren und musste dafür meine Diplomarbeit in der Antarktis machen.
Und der einzige freie Platz war sozusagen in der Fischerei.
Bis dahin hat mich Fischereibiologie nie interessiert, fand ich immer total langweilig.
Aber für eine dreimonatige Reise in die Antarktis war ich auch bereit,
meine Diplomarbeit in der Fischerei zu machen.
Das ist ja eine einmalige Gelegenheit oder?
Eigentlich schon, genau, das muss man einfach wahrnehmen als frischer Absolvent sozusagen.
Ja, also ist das jetzt so die Regel, dass da so Studenten einfach mitgenommen werden?
Oder was für eine Konstellation hat sich da ausgespielt?
Ja, ich glaube, ich habe an der richtigen Stelle gesagt, das interessiert mich sehr.
Und dann fiel jemand aus, den konnte ich ersetzen und der war halt Mitglied einer zweiköpfigen Fischereigruppe.
Sind 100 Leute an Bord, davon 60-65 Wissenschaftler, auf dieser sehr sehr langen Reise.
Einer fiel aus, musste ersetzt werden und das war ein Fischkopp.
Und deswegen war klar, wenn du was mit Fisch machst, kannst du da mit.
Das ist eher ungewöhnlich, bezahlt wurde gar nichts, war aber auch egal.
Das Abenteuer allein war gut genug.
Und so bin ich am Ende da hängengeblieben.
Nichts hat geklappt, also das, was wir uns vorgenommen hatten für meine Diplomarbeit,
hat nicht funktioniert, weil wir im Eis eingeschlossen wurden und dann da über Wochen nicht raus kamen
und da nicht fischen konnten, wo wir fischen wollten, aber am Ende ist alles gut geworden,
wie eigentlich immer.
Wow, wie lange ist man denn da unterwegs?
Das interessiert mich ja jetzt doch.
Das war eine Reise, also das ist unterschiedlich, aber in der Antarktis in der Regel
mit dem Forschungsschiff, wenn man von Südamerika oder von Südafrika aus startet,
ungefähr 8 Wochen und das war eine dreimonatige Reise von Kapstadt nach Kapstadt.
Also 8 Wochen insgesamt jetzt unterwegs, aber ich meine, wie lange fährt man,
bis man überhaupt das Gefühl hat, man ist jetzt auch da angekommen, wo man hin will?
So ungefähr 10 Tage, also von Kapstadt aus sind es 10 Tage.
Von Ushuaia von der Südspitze Südamerikas aus sind es in der Regel nur 4 oder 5 Tage.
Und wie ist das dann so da? Also ich kann mir das ja …
Unglaublich spannend.
Kalt.
Ja kalt auch, das ist nun Sommer, also es ist nicht kälter, als es bei uns im Winter ist.
Aber es ist unfassbar einsam, muss man ehrlich sagen.
Die nächste Zivilisation ist halt drei Wochen weg und es gibt alles an Tieren,
was man so aus dem Fernsehen kennt und das Licht ist unbeschreiblich,
das ist eigentlich das, was mich am allermeisten fasziniert hat.
Das Licht genau.
Das Licht?
Was ist denn mit dem Licht?
Ja das ist schwer zu beschreiben, es ist anders als hier, es ist rein.
Es ist unglaublich, also die Antarktis ist einfach was besonderes.
Und dann das Licht ist dauernd an natürlich, weil man sich ja in den hohen Breiten befindet.
Und naja dann bewegt man sich auf so einem 100 Meter langen Eisberg.
Ist da eigentlich Wolkenbildung?
Klar, gibt es alles.
Also es ist eigentlich nicht anders als hier oder?
Eigentlich ist es nicht anders als hier.
Es gibt in der Regel stabile Hochdruckwetterlagen dann im Sommer.
Also das Wetter ist eigentlich gut, in meiner Erinnerung wenigstens hat überwiegend die Sonne geschienen,
aber es gibt natürlich auch ganz andere Bedingungen, wo man dann einen Schneesturm hat und die Hand vor Augen nicht sieht.
Was ist denn mit dem Licht? Das interessiert mich ja jetzt doch.
Wie kann man denn das fassen?
Es ist anders, es ist irgendwie klarer, es ist sauberer, es ist so ein bisschen überirdisch.
Hat das jetzt schon was mit Reflexion von Eismassen zu tun?
Wahrscheinlich. Also wir arbeiten dann in der unmittelbaren Nähe dieser Schelfeise,
also dieser schwimmenden Eismassen, die 300 Meter dick sind,
das sind im Grunde aufschwimmende Gletscher.
Und das Meereis kommt dazu, in der Hochantarktis dann auch im Sommer,
deswegen ist dieser Forschungseisbrecher ein Eisbrecher, um da überhaupt durchzukommen.
Schwer zu beschreiben.
Ich war zwei Jahre später auf der amerikanischen McMurdo-Station,
die war im Grunde eine amerikanische Kleinstadt mit all dem üblichen Dreck und wie man sich das so vorstellt.
Und trotzdem in dem Moment, wo man raus war aus der Station, war das Licht wieder so, wie ich das vom Polarstern kannte.
Und sehr berührend.
Okay.
Das hat dann sozusagen den Ausschlag gegeben, sich den Fischen zuzuwenden?
Genau. Und wie das halt so ist, es ist reine Elfenbeinturmforschung.
Es gab auf der ganzen Welt vielleicht 70 Leute, die verstanden haben, was ich machte
und 15 Leute, die das wirklich interessierte, die traf man dann auch dauernd.
Aber so nach der ersten Postdoc-Periode, also ich habe da auch meine Doktorarbeit gemacht in dem Bereich,
dann vergleichen Nordpolar, Südpolar, aber nach der ersten Postdoc-Periode war klar,
das geht nicht ewig so weiter, das verschlankt sich einfach zu sehr nach oben.
Und dann habe ich das Angebot bekommen, mit Fisch weiterzumachen, aber eben angewandt.
Mein Doktorvater war damals Leiter der Bundesforschungsanstalt für Fischerei
und er hat gesagt, wenn ich mir vorstellen könnte, das Metier zu wechseln,
dann hätte er da was für mich.
Und gleich nach einem halben Jahr war das im Grunde so wie beim Biologiestudium.
Das erste halbe Jahr war das entscheidende, es war sehr sehr spannend.
Ich merkte, dass in diesem Fall die Öffentlichkeit oder die Fischerei darauf brennt,
diese Ergebnisse aus unseren Bestandsberechnungen in diesem Fall zu erfahren.
Und das war was völlig anderes als vorher, wo es wie gesagt 15 Leute gab,
die sich wirklich interessierten dafür, was ich machte, und hier gab es hunderte von Leuten,
die sich interessieren für unsere Ergebnisse möglichst aktuell.
Und auch das hat wieder so viel Spaß gemacht, dass ich einfach dabei geblieben bin.
Und dann in Hamburg in dem Institut für Seefischerei, was jetzt auch zum Thün-Institut gehört,
gearbeitet habe, da irgendwann Leiter der pelagischen Arbeitsgruppe wurde,
also der Arbeitsgruppe, die sich mit kleinen Schwarmfischen, Makrelen und Heringen und Sprotten und so weiter beschäftigte,
war da lange zuständig für die Akustik-Serways, also für die Forschungsreisen,
mit denen wir diesen Fischen nachstellen für die Bestandsberechnung,
dann im Rahmen des internationalen Rates für Meeresforschung.
Und dann zunehmend auch für die Politikempfehlung, die da rauskommt aus unseren Ergebnissen.
Und 2005 bin ich nach Rostock gekommen, bin hier stellvertretender Leiter des damals noch Instituts für Ostseefischerei der Bundesforschungsanstalt für Fischerei geworden.
Und seit 2013 bin ich Leiter der Einrichtung.
Es gab dann auch noch ein Engagement oder gibt es noch an der Universität Rostock,
ist das damit direkt verbunden?
Ja, das ist insofern damit verbunden, als wir zunehmend feststellen,
dass wir eigentlich mehr offene Stellen haben als wir qualifiziertes Personal finden.
Fischereibiologie ist im Grunde eine Grenzdisziplin zwischen der reinen Biologie,
es gibt viele gute Biologen, gerade gut Feldbiologen, die das ganz toll finden,
rauszufahren und Fische zu suchen oder Fische zu analysieren und so weiter.
Aber was wir brauchen ist ein hohes Maß an Mathematik und Statistik,
um am Ende die Fischbestände berechnen zu können.
Und da wird es dann schnell dünn.
Die Leute, die sich mit Mathematik und Statistik gut auskennen, die interessieren sich wenig für Lebewesen,
und die Feldbiologen sozusagen haben meistens eine Schwäche auf der statistischen Seite.
Und wir haben irgendwann festgestellt, dass wir die Ausbildung einfach selber betreiben müssen,
um gute Leute eben für Doktorandenstellen zum Beispiel zu finden.
Und das war so der Punkt, wo wir angefangen haben, uns in die Lehre intensiver mit einzubringen.
Und wir machen seit letzten Jahr ein eigenes Modul sogar, ein Modul angewandte Fischereibiologie im Studiengang integrative Zoologie an der Uni Rostock.
Wir sind schon seit vielen Jahren über den Aquakultur-Studiengang mit der Uni verbunden,
aber das ist ein kleineres Engagement sozusagen, wo wir einzelne Vorlesungen oder einzelne Blöcke übernehmen,
aber kein ganzes Modul haben.
Und das funktioniert dann auch?
Das funktioniert gut.
Wir feilen an den Formaten noch.
Wir wollen gerne, … wir machen das ja sozusagen nebenher.
Unser Auftraggeber, das Bundeslandwirtschaftsministerium, fördert das in keiner Weise.
Wir machen das also im Grunde im Nebenamt bis zu einer gewissen Grenze.
Alles, was darüber hinausgeht, machen wir in unserer Freizeit.
Und ich möchte gerne möglichst viele Mitarbeiter des Hauses auch einbinden,
weil die dann Studenten kennenlernen, die dann in ihren Abteilungen jeweils Abschlussarbeiten oder sogar Promotionen anfertigen können.
Und wir sind alle gerade in der Hauptsaison, die jetzt ist, sehr sehr viel unterwegs,
insofern müssen wir an dem Format so ein bisschen feilen.
Wir haben im Grunde so eine Art Ringvorlesung für zwei Semester eingerichtet,
wo die Fachleute über ihren Bereich den Studenten was berichten können.
Das ist logistisch ein bisschen aufwendig, weil das immer so halbe Tage sind
oder hier mal zwei Stunden, da mal zwei Stunden und dann gibt es ganze Blockkurse,
wo wir versuchen, die Studenten mit auf unsere Schiffe zu nehmen, weil das für einen Meeresforscher natürlich das Highlight ist rauszufahren einfach.
Na ich denke mir, dass das eh so für die Studierenden natürlich eine super Gelegenheit ist,
auch einfach mal so einen Praxisbezug zu bekommen, den ja ein Studium jetzt nicht unbedingt immer automatisch mitbringt.
Ganz genau, und Schiffszeiten sind unfassbar teuer, die meisten Schiffe.
Es gibt einen Schiffspool der deutschen Forschungsschiffe, die sind überwiegend über Jahre ausgebucht,
auch für studentische Ausbildung, aber eben über Jahre ausgebucht.
Und wir haben das große Glück, dass wir Ressortforschungseinrichtung über drei Schiffe verfügen,
die wir relativ frei einsetzen können.
Da gibt es also im Moment wenigstens wenig Konkurrenz.
Und wir bemühen uns, jede freie Minute dann auch extern anzubieten, um die Schiffe wirklich in Fahrt zu halten,
weil wir wissen, wie teuer die sind.
Aber wir nutzen sie eben auch.
Jedes dieser Schiffe ist ungefähr 260-270 Tage im Jahr auf See.
Wir reden jetzt von konkreten Forschungsschiffen?
Ja.
Was können die?
Also was unterscheidet die jetzt von anderen Forschungsschiffen vielleicht?
Also erst mal, Forschungsschiffe sind natürlich eine ganz wesentliche Plattform für die Meeresforschung,
weil wir als Landlebewesen irgendwas brauchen, womit wir aufs Meer fahren,
solange wir das nicht volldigitalisiert und ferngesteuert machen können.
Das wird vielleicht irgendwann passieren, aber da haben wir immer noch mindestens 30 oder 40 Jahre Zeit,
bis wir das sozusagen von Land mit dem Joystick machen können.
Unsere drei Forschungsschiffe sind spezialisierte Fischereiforschungsschiffe.
Wie der Name schon sagt, die können eben fischen.
Das können die allermeisten anderen Forschungsschiffe nicht, die meistens Mehrzweckforschungsschiffe sind.
Und für die Geologie Schwerelose einsetzen können oder kleine Netze ziehen.
Aber wirklich im sozusagen kommerziellen Maßstab verlässlich Fischfang,
dafür braucht man eine sehr spezielle Ausrüstung.
Das fängt an mit den Einrichtungen, um Fische zu detektieren,
also spezial Forschungsecholote, die sehr sehr aufwändig sind,
weil sie mit vielen verschiedenen Frequenzen ins Meer pingen,
um zu gucken, was für Fische da unten leben, wie groß die sind, wie schwer die sind.
Dann muss man die Fische fangen, trotz dieser akustischen Methoden.
Dafür braucht man zum Teil sehr sehr große Netze und Spezialwinden,
die die allermeisten anderen Forschungsschiffe nicht an Bord haben.
Und man den Fisch, der dann an Deck kommt, auch verarbeiten können.
Nicht jetzt für den menschlichen Konsum, sondern eben für die Forschung.
Aber auch dafür braucht man im Grunde ein spezielles Setup,
für das auf den allermeisten normalen Forschungsschiffen gar kein Platz wäre.
Also diese Schiffe ähneln in gewisser Hinsicht sehr viel mehr einem normalen Fischereiboot?
Von …
Plus weitere Einrichtungen?
Von der Fangkapazität her schon, aber normale Fischereifahrzeuge werden dann eben,
wenn die so die Größe unserer Schiffe haben, von zwischen 2 und 10 Leuten betrieben,
während bei uns schon auf das kleinste Schiff dann 4 Wissenschaftler passen.
Und das größte Forschungsschiff, was wir jetzt gerade ersetzen, wird am Ende dann Platz für 26 Wissenschaftler und 26 Mann Besatzung haben.
Das ist dann also vorne sozusagen Hotel, in der Mitte ist es voll mit hochtechnologisierten Laboren
und hinten ist es dann ein normales Fischereifahrzeug.
Nicht schlecht, drei in eins.
Genau.
Wie lange sind die dann unterwegs?
Na die längsten Reisen auf dem großen Forschungsschiff sind so in der Regel 7-8 Wochen ungefähr.
Das ist dann schon ziemlich lang.
Das mittlere Forschungsschiff hat eine Reichweite von etwas über drei Wochen.
Jetzt unsere Solea, die unser spezialisiertes Akustikschiff ist,
ist gerade in der Ostsee unterwegs, Anfang der Woche gestartet.
Und diese Reise dauert ungefähr 22 Tage.
Jetzt ist ja das Thün-Institut nicht nur ein Institut für die Fischereiforschung,
sondern es geht ja konkret um die Ostsee, also es gibt hier eine Spezialisierung oder sogar eine Festlegung.
Ist da nur die Ostsee im Fokus oder steht es nur im Vordergrund?
Na das Thün-Institut als Thün-Institut ist sogar noch viel weiter gefasst,
weil wir Ökonomieinstitute, Forst- und Holzinstitute, Landwirtschaftsinstitute und dann drei Fischereiinstitute haben.
Und diese drei Fischereiinstitute, das ist sozusagen die alte Bundesforschungsanstalt für Fischerei,
die beschäftigt sich mit Meeresfischerei im weitesten Sinne.
Und wir haben jetzt drei Institute, zwei in Bremerhaven, das Institut für Seefischerei,
was sich im Grunde mit dem Weltmeer und der Nordsee befasst,
aber darüber hinaus auch mit der Fischereiökonomie zum Beispiel.
Das Institut für Fischereiökologie, die machen viel Aquakultur, aber auch viel Schadstoffe im Meer und Aal.
Und wir sind das Institut für Ostseefischerei, also eins von 14 Thün-Instituten, ein Unterinstitut,
und unser geografischer Schwerpunkt liegt in der Tat auf der Ostsee,
das ist ziemlich einleuchtend.
Also wir kümmern uns um den Zustand der durch den Menschen genutzten nachwachsenden Ressourcen in der Ostsee,
aber darüber hinaus haben wir auch übergreifende Aufgaben.
Bei uns ist zum Beispiel die gesamte Fischerei und Serway-Technik angesiedelt.
Also wenn es darum geht, Netze nachhaltiger zu machen, meistens bedeutet das,
sie selektiver zu machen, also wir wollen nur das fangen oder wir wollen,
dass der Fischer nur das fängt, was er auch haben will und was er vermarkten kann,
dann ist das egal, ob Nord- oder Ostsee oder offener Nordatlantik, bei  uns beheimatet.
Oder wir sind zuständig für neue Politikkonzepte, wenn es irgendwie darum geht,
mal was ganz anders zu denken und zu sagen, so haben wir das die letzten 35 Jahre gemacht,
aber muss man das eigentlich so machen, kann man das nicht auch anders machen?
Dann ist das sozusagen in unserem Forschungsbereich.
Wenn es darum geht herauszufinden, wie ticken Fische eigentlich?
Was sind Anreize für die, die wir gerne schaffen wollen, damit Fischer sich so benehmen,
wie wir als Eigner der Ressource Meeresfisch das gerne haben wollen, dann ist das bei uns.
Und dazu zählt zum Beispiel Eco-Labeling, diese ganze Nachhaltigkeitszertifizierung von Fischereiprodukten,
da sitzen bundesweit die Experten im Wildfischbereich tatsächlich in meinem Institut.
Aber der Fokus liegt auf der Ostsee.
Jetzt ist ja die Ostsee ein ganz besonderes Meer.
Mir ist das selber, ich bin ja eigentlich nicht so ein Meeresmensch muss ich zugeben,
ich komme so ein bisschen aus dem Flachland und so, ich habe es mit der Küste genauso wenig wie mit den Bergen.
Vielleicht merke ich aber dadurch auch Dinge, die vielleicht banal sind, irgendwie auf eine andere Art und Weise.
Letztes Mal, als ich an der Ostsee war, ist mir wieder klar geworden, wie sehr der Name See irgendwie zutrifft,
weil im Vergleich zu den anderen Meeren kommt halt die Ostsee auch mehr wie so ein See rüber.
Nicht so mega salzig, irgendwie ruhiger, ist anders.
Inwiefern ist denn die Ostsee jetzt eine Besonderheit unter den Meeren und inwiefern hat das dann Einfluss hier auf die Arbeit?
Ja die Ostsee ist ein abgeschlossenes Randmeer erstens,
das heißt, sie hat keinen direkten Zustrom vom offenen Ozean, anders als die Nordsee,
wo der Golfstrom einfach durchgeht und dauernd für frisches Wasser sorgt.
Es ist abgeschlossen, es ist ein sehr junges Meer.
Die Ostsee selbst, so wie wir sie jetzt kennen, ist nur ungefähr 8.000 Jahre alt.
Bis dahin war sie tatsächlich ein Süßwassersee, der einen Abfluss in die Nordsee hatte,
aber diese Verbindung zwischen Nordsee und Ostsee ist erst vor ungefähr 8.000 Jahren aufgebrochen.
Und erst seitdem gibt es hier überhaupt Salzwasser, weil das nämlich von der Nordsee reingekommen ist.
Die Ostsee selbst hat keine eigenen Salzlagerstätten, das heißt,
sie würde immer weiter aussüßen, sie wäre im Grunde am Ende ein See,
wenn nicht gelegentlich Salzwasser aus der Nordsee reingedrückt würde.
Dafür braucht man bestimmte Wetterlagen und das ist wieder ein ganz spannendes Thema,
weil diese Wetterlagen in den letzten Jahren immer weniger geworden sind
und die Ostsee dadurch tatsächlich immer süßer wurde, wenigstens an der Oberfläche.
Denn salziges Wasser ist schwerer als süßes Wasser, und deswegen setzt sich das salzige Wasser in der Tiefe ab.
Die Ostsee ist eine Abfolge dieser Becken mit einer sehr flachen Schwelle zwischen der dänische Insel zur Nordsee.
Und alles, was an salzhaltigem, aber eben auch sauerstoffreichem Wasser in die Ostsee rein soll,
um die tiefen Becken zu belüften, muss aus der Nordsee kommen.
Und wenn das ausbleibt, dann bleibt das Salz zwar im Wasser, aber der Sauerstoffgehalt in den tiefen Becken wird immer weniger
und dadurch haben wir in der Ostsee massive Probleme mit diesen großen sogenannten Todeszonen.
Das hören wir nicht so gerne, weil es natürlich andere Organismen gibt,
Schwefelbakterien oder so was, denen das überhaupt nichts ausmacht
und die mit mehr Sauerstoff eher größere Probleme hätten.
Aber für uns Menschen sind Gebiete mit einem hohen Schwefelwasserstoffgehalt einfach lebensfeindlich.
Und für Seesäuger und eben auch für die von uns genutzten Fische auch.
Deswegen ist die Ostsee ein besonderes Meer.
Das, was wir reinkippen, bleibt sehr sehr lange drin, angefangen von Giften,
die zum Teil Schwermetalle oder so was, die zum Teil aus der Schwerindustrie oder aus dem Kohlebergbau kommen oder so was,
das passiert schon seit 70-80 Jahren nicht mehr, und dennoch sind diese Gifte alle immer noch nachweisbar,
aber noch viel mehr mit Nährstoffeinträgen aus der Landwirtschaft, aus dem Verkehr,
aus der öffentlichen Versorgung und so weiter.
Alles, was in die Ostsee reinkommt, bleibt da erst mal und es dauert viele viele Jahre,
bis das wieder rausgeht oder sich verbessert.
Das heißt, die Ostsee verdient sich ihren Namen, es ist eigentlich so ein gescheiterter See?
In gewisser Hinsicht so. Aber mir war das gar nicht so klar, dass das noch gar nicht so lange her ist,
8.000 Jahre ist ja quasi nix.
Das ist nix, in geologischen Zeiträumen ist das nix.
Und aber dieser Zustrom ist schon permanent oder hängt das auch so von irgendwelchen Zyklen ab,
wie viel Salzwasser da jetzt wirklich eingetragen wird?
Das hängt mit Sicherheit von irgendwas ab, aber wovon genau das abhängt, wissen wir leider nicht genau.
Wir wissen, was wir für einen Mechanismus brauchen, schon deshalb weil wir den alle Jahre mal wieder beobachten können.
Der letzte starke Salzwassereinstrom war Nikolaus 2015 und Anfang 2016 gab es weitere starke Salzwassereinströme.
Dafür braucht man eine bestimmte Wetterlage.
Man braucht starken Ostwind, der die Ostsee sozusagen leer pustet.
Denn im Regelfall ist der Wasserstand in der Ostsee ein bisschen höher als in der Nordsee.
Das heißt, das Süßwasser aus den Flüssen fließt in die Ostsee und dann irgendwann durch die Beltsee und durch die Belte,
also den dänischen Inseln vorbei in die Nordsee.
Und man braucht starken Ostwind, der die Ostsee leer pustet,
dann ist das Gefälle genau andersrum und dann muss der Wind um 180 Grad drehen
und man braucht starken Wind aus westlichen Richtungen, der dann das salzige Nordseewasser reindrückt.
Und wenn das gelingt, dann strömt das Salzwasser sozusagen, wenn es mal durch die Belte durch ist,
am Boden, weil es so schwer ist, von einem Becken zum anderen.
Füllt das nächste Becken, also das Arkonabecken in diesem Fall,
westlich von Bornholm auf und wenn eine bestimmte Höhe erreicht ist unter dem Meer,
dann strömt es über in das Bornholmbecken und füllt das auf.
Und wenn der Salzwassereinstrom immer noch anhält, dann strömt es über in das Gotlandbecken zum Beispiel.
Und das passiert dann schon sehr sehr selten.
Das ist wiederum wichtig für unsere Fischfauna, also für das, was uns als Thün-Institut für Ostseefischerei besonders interessiert,
weil die Fischfauna der Ostsee besteht aus menschlicher Sicht im Wesentlichen aus fünf Arten,
die kommerziell genutzt werden können.
Es gibt natürlich ein paar mehr Arten, viele Süßwasserarten darunter im Küstengebiet,
aber 95% der Erträge, der Fischerträge aus der Ostsee sind fünf Salzwasserfischarten,
die einfach aus der Nordsee eingewandert sind
und im Grunde nach wie vor angepasst sind an salziges Wasser.
Wenn also viel salziges und sauerstoffreiches Wasser da ist, geht es den Beständen gut.
Wenn das nicht mehr da ist, weil dieser Zustrom ausbleibt, weil die Wetterlage sich geändert hat,
dann geht es denen nicht mehr so gut.
Und während wir sagen, dass in den allermeisten Gebieten der Welt die Fischerei als direkte menschliche Nutzung den wesentlichen Einfluss auf den Zustand von Fischbeständen hat,
ist es in der Ostsee eher 50/50, also ungefähr 50% sind direkter menschlicher Einfluss durch Fischerei,
50% sind die Umweltbedingungen, die sehr sehr variabel sind.
Das heißt, so vor 8.000 Jahren gab es keinen dieser Fische?
Genau, da gab es so ein paar Süßwasserfische.
Aber nicht in den Mengen?
Wahrscheinlich nicht in den Mengen, weil viele Salzwasserfische deutlich produktiver sind als Süßwasserfische.
Warum?
Keine Ahnung, gute Frage.
Die sind irgendwie umtriebiger?
Ja, die sind irgendwie umtriebiger.
Salz scheint zu helfen...
Genau
Aha, okay. Macht man sich ja nicht so klar.
Was sind denn diese fünf Fische, Fischarten?
Das ist von der Menge angefangen Hering mit großem Abstand und Sprotte.
Das sind so die beiden, also kleine Schwarmfischbestände, das sind die,
die die allermeiste Biomasse ausmachen und dann auch jetzt die allermeisten Anlandungen ausmachen.
Dann gibt es Dorsch ganz prominent, als einziges wesentlichen Weißfisch sozusagen,
der vor allen Dingen für die südlichen Anrainer, also für Dänemark, Deutschland und Polen für die Fischerei besondere Bedeutung hat.
Es gibt eine Reihe von Plattfischen, ungefähr 3-4 verschiedene Arten.
Ganz zum salzigen Teil hin, also zu den dänischen Inseln hin, gibt es noch Seezungen.
Dann gibt es bei uns vor der Küste Scholle.
Es gibt relativ viel Flunder und Kliesche, ab und zu ein bisschen Steinbutt,
aber in sehr geringen Dichten.
Also das sind so ein paar Arten, die wir mehr so unter diverse Plattfische summieren.
All diese Arten werden immer seltener, je weiter ich nach Osten und nach Norden dann in den bottnischen Meerbusen komme.
Und nördlich der Olandinseln, die also die Südgrenze des bottnischen Meerbusen beschreiben,
nördlich dieser Inseln haben wir im Grunde nur noch Heringe und ein kleines bisschen Sprotte.
Alle anderen Fische schaffen es physiologisch nicht mehr, da zu leben oder wenigstens sich fortzupflanzen.
Also die könnte man da vielleicht noch hin geleiten, die wären lebensfähig,
aber sie wären eben nicht fortpflanzungsfähig.
Ein Hering kann das.
Das heißt, die Konzentration der Fischerei in der Ostsee liegt auch eher im westlichen Bereich, kann man das so sagen?
Was die Diversität angeht, ja, da ist im östlichen Bereich sehr …
Also der östliche Bereich ist viel größer als der westliche Bereich, das muss man dazu sagen.
Deswegen sind es im westlichen Bereich überwiegend, also in der westlichen Ostsee,
westlich von Bornholm bis zur Nordkante der dänischen Inseln, sind es überwiegend kleine Fischereien,
während größere Fischereifahrzeuge, die dann aber in der Regel Schwarmfischfänger sind,
auch in der östlichen Ostsee operieren können.
Also wenn man sich nur die Mengen anguckt, kommt tatsächlich mehr Fischbiomasse in den Anlandungen aus der östlichen Ostsee,
aber wenn man das pro Quadratmeter Fläche auf den Quadratmeter Fläche bezieht,
dann ist der Westen deutlich produktiver.
Aber der Osten, also ich meine wie zählt man denn das?
Ich meine, die Ostsee geht ja extrem weit nach oben nach Schweden.
Also der Westteil ist ja eigentlich kleiner als der Ostteil?
Genau, der Westteil ist viel kleiner.
Man sagt, die westliche Ostsee ist der Bereich, der südlich an das Kattegat anschließt.
Also wenn man von der Nordsee kommt, und dann um Skagen, um Jütland durch die norwegische Rinne durchgeht,
dann kommt erst das Skagerrak, dann kommt das Kattegat bis zu den dänischen Inseln
und alles südlich der dänischen Inseln, bis ungefähr Bornholm, ist die westliche Ostsee
und alles östlich von Bornholm ist die östliche Ostsee, die man dann wieder in die zentrale Ostsee,
den Golf von Riga, den finnischen Meerbusen und den bottnischen Meerbusen unterteilt.
Schafft es das Salz denn überhaupt bis ganz in den Osten?
In den letzten 30 Jahren eben nicht mehr.
Da braucht man sehr sehr starke Einstromereignisse.
Und der letzte sehr starke Einstrom wie gesagt aus dem Herbst 2015 …
Vor ein paar Jahren.
der hat es bis in das Gotlandbecken geschafft, da kann man ihn nachweisen,
aber der hat auch da nicht dazu geführt, dass das Gotlandbecken jetzt gut belüftet wäre
oder aufgefüllt mit frischem Wasser, also mit salzhaltigem frischen Wasser.
Das heißt, dass man auch diese Fischarten dort nicht findet?
Genau, da oben gibt es keinen Dorsch, da gibt es keine Plattfische.
Das hört dann auf ein paar hundert Meilen östlich von Bornholm.
Das heißt, das wird auch nicht so aktiv befischt?
Also auf diese Fischarten gar nicht befischt, weil es die ja nicht gibt.
Na ist klar, aber es gibt auch sonst nicht so viel, was man jetzt fischen könnte?
Ja doch, es gibt dann eine Lachsfischerei, das ist eine sehr wertvolle Fischerei, die weniger erträgt
und es gibt wie gesagt eine sehr vitale Schwarmfischfischerei.
Denn Heringe und Sprotten die leben da auch, die haben sogar ihren Verbreitungsschwerpunkt da.
Also es gibt letztlich mehr Hering und vor allen Dingen mehr Sprotte zwischen den Olands,
also zwischen dem finnischen Meerbusen und der zentralen Ostsee, als es in der westlichen Ostsee gibt.
Okay. Sind gut unterwegs die Heringe.
Wie hat sich denn diese Fischerei so entwickelt?
Ich meine, wir haben jetzt diese ganze Diskussion um die Fischerei.
Ist ja immer von, oh es wird viel zu viel gefischt, die Fischbestände sinken und man muss das jetzt entsprechend reduzieren.
Also die Fischerei ist ja an sich ein politischer Diskussionspunkt,
was sozusagen diese gesamte Ernährungsdebatte der Menschheit betrifft.
Wie hat sich denn das entwickelt?
Ich meine, wenn das jetzt alles auch erst seit ein paar tausend Jahren existiert,
gut die Menschheit hat ja dann auch erst nachgezogen mit ihrer Entwicklung,
was ist so der Stand der Dinge?
Wie hat sich da vor allem so in den letzten paar hundert Jahren denn entwickelt?
Was wird da befischt und wird zu viel befischt?
Ja, wie hat sich das entwickelt?
Also Hering, gerade Hering ist im Grunde eine Ressource, die schon sehr sehr lange genutzt wird.
Im Grunde baut die ganze Hanse darauf auf.
Das war im Grunde Skagen- und Skanör-Hering, der dicht an der Küste gefangen werden konnte.
Da brauchte man zum Haltbarmachen Salz, das kam aus Lüneburg zum Beispiel
oder wo immer man Salz finden konnte.
Und diese Handelswege, Fisch in die eine Richtung, Konservierungsmittel Salz in die andere Richtung
und alles gemeinsam, also den konservierten Hering irgendwo anders hin,
das war im Grunde die Grundsteine der Entwicklung der Hanse.
Das musste dann geschützt werden gegen Piraten und so weiter.
Also wir wissen, seit dem frühen Mittelalter im Grunde wird das Ganze auch in großem Stil gefischt und seitdem genutzt
und seitdem weiß man auch, dass die Heringe mal da sind und mal nicht da sind.
Wie die genau funktionieren diese Zyklen, ist nicht ganz klar.
An der Überfischung kann es damals kaum gelegen haben, dass die ausgeblieben sind.
Denn es blieb eine sehr kleine Küstenfischerei, sie war nicht mechanisiert,
die Ordnungsmethoden waren nicht besonders gut, sondern die Fischer haben halt genutzt,
was ihnen sozusagen vor die Nase schwamm.
Aber seitdem ist gerade Hering eine sehr sehr wertvolle Ressource, auch in der Ostsee.
Geändert hat sich die Fischereipraxis im Grunde erst mit der Erfindung der Dampfmaschine, wie überall.
Da wurde es mechanisiert, die Kutter konnten länger draußen bleiben, konnten größere Netze ziehen.
Aus der Stellnetzfischerei, die wir zu den stillen Fischereien zählen,
also eine Fischerei, die Netze aufstellt und wartet darauf, dass die Fische ins Netz gehen,
wurde eine aktive Fischerei, durch die Möglichkeit, Netze zu ziehen.
Und da wurde man wenigstens in anderen Gebieten der Welt, nicht so sehr in Ostsee,
sehr schnell darauf aufmerksam, dass Fischbestände keineswegs unendlich sind,
sondern eben endlich und wenn man nicht anfängt, sie vernünftig zu bewirtschaften,
dann haben die irgendwann ein Ende.
Das heißt nicht, dass sie aussterben, denn in aller Regel sind sie so weit verbreitet,
dass der letzte Fisch tatsächlich nicht gefischt werden kann.
Es bleiben immer Schwärme übrig, die so produktiv sind, dass sich auch katastrophal überfischte,
kollabierte Fischbestände innerhalb weniger Jahre erholen können.
Beispiel ist der Nordseehering mit der Erfindung der Ringwade.
In den 60er Jahre wurde der so überfischt, dass am Ende noch 50.000 Tonnen erwachsene Tiere übrig waren.
Normalerweise sollte der Bestand so bei 1,3 Millionen Tonnen groß sein.
Daraufhin wurde 1977 die Fischerei geschlossen und schon vier Jahre später konnte sie wieder eröffnet werden,
weil der Bestand in diesen vier Jahren so viel Nachwuchs produziert hat, dass der Bestand auf gutem Wege war.
Und ein paar Jahre später hatte er sich erholt.
Also marine Fischbestände sind unfassbar produktiv.
Im Grunde reicht theoretisch ein einziges Pärchen, um eine Bestand wieder aufzubauen.
Das will man natürlich nicht.
Und man muss eben nur dafür sorgen, dass die auch die Gelegenheit bekommen, das zu tun.
Mit der Industrialisierung sozusagen oder mit der technischeren Nutzung war dann klar,
wir brauchen ein gemeinsames Management, Fischbestände wandern,
halten sich nicht an nationalstaatliche Grenzen und wenn die deutsche Regierung beschließt,
wir setzen die Fangmengen so und so fest, wir setzen irgendeine Grenze fest und die anderen halten sich nicht,
macht das wenig Sinn.
Das führte schon 1902 dazu, dass eine internationale, die älteste internationale zwischenstaatliche Organisation überhaupt,
der internationale Rat für Meeresforschung in Kopenhagen gegründet wurde.
Und diese Organisation kümmert sich seit 1902 darum, die wissenschaftlichen Daten aus allen interessierten Ländern,
also allen Ländern, die auf einen bestimmten Fischbestand fischen, zusammenzutragen,
den Bestand zu begutachten und am Ende aus der Begutachtung Empfehlungen für die Politik abzuleiten,
wie man einen solchen Bestand nachhaltig bewirtschaften könnte.
Nun gibt es viele Leute, die sagen, das ist alles sehr aufwendig, das brauchen wir alles gar nicht.
Die kleine Küstenfischerei, wenn man die nur fördern würde, und die großen Trawler verbieten würde, dann wäre alles gut.
Das sehen wir völlig anders.
Erstens reicht auch die Kapazität der kleinen Küstenfahrzeuge dicke aus, um Bestände zu überfischen.
Es kommt nicht darauf an, ob es tausend kleine oder fünf große machen,
sondern es kommt am Ende nur darauf an, wie die entnehmen.
Und ein großes Fahrzeug kann exakt genauso nachhaltig fischen wie viele kleine.
All diese Fischereimethoden haben ihr Vorteile und ihre Nachteile.
Und deswegen können wir das gar nicht abwägen gegeneinander und sagen,
große Fahrzeuge sind schlecht, kleine Fahrzeuge sind gut oder genau andersrum.
Wir wissen, dass kleine Fahrzeuge größere Probleme bei der Einhaltung der Regeln und bei den Beifängen von meinetwegen Seevögeln haben.
Große Fahrzeuge fischen dafür in der Regel unselektiver,
haben also größere Probleme bei den unerwünschten Fischbeifängen.
Können natürlich viel mehr anrichten in der gleichen Zeiteinheit,
sind dafür aber viel leichter überwachbar, weil die vollgestopft sind mit technischen Möglichkeiten,
um zu sehen, was sie genau wo machen und so weiter.
Wichtig ist, dass man am Ende die Fanglimitationen einhält.
Die Forschung dafür ist relativ günstig.
So im langfristigen Schnitt geben wir ungefähr 2% für Forschung, für die Analyse der Fischbestände aus.
2% vom Anlandeerlös und da beginnt die Wertschöpfungskette ja erst.
Da kommt die ganze Verarbeitung und der Handel dazu, also das ist vergleichsweise günstig.
Und wenn man das lassen würde und einfach sagen würde, wir geben die Nutzung der Fischbestände frei,
dann würden die allermeisten Fischbestände sehr sehr schnell zusammenbrechen.
Da kann man sie immer noch nutzen, aber nur ungefähr 10% der jetzigen Menge.
Insofern ist es keine gute Idee zu sagen, man kann das Management einfach lassen,
man braucht kein Fangmengenbegrenzung oder so was, die für Ausgleich sorgen.
Die Fangmengenbegrenzungen sollen dafür sorgen, dass Fischbestände optimal genutzt werden.
Nicht einfach nur genutzt werden, sondern optimal genutzt werden,
weil ein optimal genutzter Bestand liefert viel viel mehr Ertrag für die menschliche Ernährung als ein nicht optimal genutzter Bestand.
Dieses Verständnis existiert schon seit 1902 oder das kam dann erst in der Folge?
Nein das existent im Grunde von Anfang an.
Was genau man jetzt unter optimaler Nutzung versteht, das hat sich im Lauf der Zeit geändert.
Das ist ein Konzept im Grunde, was in den 60er Jahren entwickelt wurde.
Das nennen wieder Maximum Sustainable Yield, also maximaler nachhaltiger Dauerertrag.
Das wurde dann in den 90er Jahren nochmal umdefiniert sozusagen,
wo man gesagt hat, nein der Vorsorgeansatz, dass wir nur versuchen, Schaden von den Fischbeständen abzuwehren,
also sie so groß zu halten, dass sie nicht deswegen weniger produktiv werden,
weil es nicht mehr genügend Elterntiere gibt, das ändern wir und wir sagen,
nein wir wollen, dass die Bestände noch größer sind, damit sie auch bei schwankenden Umweltbedingungen immer möglichst den maximal nachhaltigen Dauerertrag abgeben.
Und das Ganze mündete in die Johannesburg-Konferenz 2002, der auch die Europäische Union zugestimmt hat.
Seitdem haben wir eine allgemein global gültige Bewirtschaftungsregel für marine Fischbestände,
die sich eben daran orientiert, wir beschließen als Weltgemeinschaft, wir wollen marine Fischbestände,
wilde Fischbestände nutzen, wir wollen sie auf hohem Niveau nutzen,
aber wir wollen sie nicht übernutzen, weil sie dann nicht mehr den maximalen Ertrag liefern.
Dem sind alle Staaten beigetreten oder auf welcher Ebene ist das, eine UN-Initiative?
Genau, das ist eine UN-Regel, und im Grunde haben alle Staaten weltweit, also es gibt sicher Ausnahmen von kleinen Staaten,
aber die wesentlichen Staaten, die Fischbestände bewirtschaften, unter anderem eben die Europäische Union,
die für uns maßgeblich ist, haben dieser Regel zugestimmt.
Und es hat dennoch 15-20 Jahre gedauert, bis die dann sozusagen in europäische Gesetzgebung hart überführt wurde.
Das haben wir erst seit 2014, seit der letzten Reform der gemeinsamen Fischereipolitik,
vorher hat sich der Gesetzgeber an diesen Richtlinien orientiert, aber es war kein festgeschriebenes Gesetz.
Seit 2014 muss der Ministerrat der europäische und die Europäische Kommission diesen Regeln folgen.
Okay. Jetzt, also das beutetet ja, wenn man diese …
Was war, diesen Maximum Yield, diesen optimale Ausschöpfung sozusagen der Fischmasse erzeugen will,
muss das ja auch in irgendeiner Form quantifiziert werden.
Also man muss ja die Bestände irgendwie kennen, messen, verfolgen, über einen längeren Zeitraum mitschreiben, quantifizieren,
und natürlich auch die Entnahme sozusagen gegenrechnen.
Ist stelle mir vor, dass das jetzt ein relativ komplexes Netzwerk von unterschiedlichen Sensoriken ist,
sowohl wirtschaftlichen Sensoriken als auch konkreten auf der See-Sensoriken.
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen, wie dieser Organismus zusammenarbeitet?
Also wie schafft es … also beschränken wir uns jetzt mal nur auf die Ostsee, nicht die ganze Welt.
Wie arbeiten die Anrainerstaaten zusammen, welche Rolle nimmt jetzt auch dieser Council da konkret ein und Ihr Institut?
Was für Daten müssen überhaupt erst mal erhoben werden und wo kriegt man die her?
Also es fängt an damit, dass wir wie gesagt Landbewohner sind und das Meer für uns nicht nur ein bisschen mystisch,
sondern vor allen Dingen undurchsichtig und endlos ist.
Das ist auch tatsächlich so.
Wir können viele viele Proben nehmen, wir müssen viele viele Proben nehmen, aber sie werden immer ein Tropfen im Meer sein.
Also egal, wo wir eine Probe nehmen, es kann immer an der falschen Stelle sein.
Und statistisch kriegen wir das nur raus, indem wir unfassbar viele Proben nehmen.
Aber wir können am Ende eben nicht den Stöpsel ziehen, das Wasser rauslassen, Fische zählen, Wasser wieder reinlassen.
Sondern wir sind immer auf indirekte Methoden angewiesen, die eine gewisse Unsicherheit haben.
Weil wir nicht wissen, ob wir das, was wir da gefunden haben, eine Meile daneben genauso ist oder vielleicht völlig anders ist.
Klar.
Um das rauszukriegen betreiben wir sehr sehr viel Aufwand.
Wir nehmen im Wesentlichen Daten aus der kommerziellen Fischerei.
Also die Anlandedaten, wir beproben die Anlandung sehr ausführlich.
Also Anlandedaten heißt, was konkret an Fisch in den Häfen angeliefert wird?
Ganz genau.
Was gewogen wird, aufgezeichnet wird etc..
Ganz genau, dafür gibt es Fangstatistiken, die sind inzwischen sehr gut und auch sehr verlässlich bei den allermeisten Fahrzeugen
oder Metiers, bei den allermeisten Fischereien.
Die beproben wir, gucken uns genau an, in welcher Altersstruktur liegen die vor.
Also wieviele dreijährige Dorsche wurden angelandet, vierjährige, fünfjährige.
In welchem Ernährungszustand waren?
Wie war das Geschlechterverhältnis Männchen, Weibchen?
In welchem Reifezustand waren die?
Das sind alles Daten, die uns am Ende helfen, zu beurteilen, ob der Bestand in gutem oder schlechtem Zustand ist.
Wie, das wird jetzt bei jedem Fang, der im Hafen anlandet, wird einzeln geguckt, wie alt die Fische sind?
Nein natürlich nicht.
Wir nehmen Stichproben, wie man das üblicherweise macht, wenn also, keine Ahnung, 6.000 Tonnen Dorsch hat,
dann nehmen wir übers Jahr verteilt 50 oder 60 Proben, die ungefähr 300-350 Kilo umfangen.
Die werden dann analysiert.
Das ist immer noch eine ganze Menge Fisch, was dann hier durchs Labor geht.
Und dann wird das Alter bestimmt, das ist ein ziemlich aufwendiger Prozess,…
Man schaut sich dann jeden einzelnen Fisch an?
Da schaut man sich jeden von dieser Unterproben, 350 Kilo, schauen wir uns jeden einzelnen Fisch an.
So manuell auf den Tisch legen, gucken was ist das?
Genau.
Gibt es keinen Scanner, wo man die irgendwie durchjagen kann?
Leider nicht, und die tragen auch keine Geburtsurkunden mit sich rum
und sie reagieren auch nicht Befragung, wie alt sie denn sind
und deswegen machen wir uns zunutze, dass es Hartstrukturen im Körper,
diese Gehörsteinchen, Otolithen, gibt, die Ringe wie ein Baumring anlegen.
Und idealerweise jedes Jahr einen neuen.
Da gibt es dann manchmal auch Zweifel, weil die leider zum Beispiel -
jetzt wird es wieder sehr Ostsee-spezifisch – auch Ringe anlegen, wenn sie den Wasserkörper ändern.
Also wenn sie von sehr salzarmem in sehr heizhaltiges Wasser kommen,
legen die einfach einen Ring an.
Und wenn sie das viermal innerhalb eines Jahres machen, legen die vier Ringe an,
was bei uns so aussieht in der Analyse, als ob es vier Jahre wären.
Da wird es sehr komplex, das ist aber überall woanders nicht so
Okay, aber man muss schon den Fisch so richtig sezieren, entnehmen, genau drauf gucken, etc., also viel manuelle Arbeit?
Genau, jeder einzelne Fisch wird gründlich auseinandergenommen, auch was die Reife angeht
oder die Mageninhalte, den Ernährungszustand, das müssen wir mit jedem einzelnen Fisch machen.
Okay, aber so rein jetzt von der Größe her, vom Gewicht her, kann man da jetzt keine Schlüsse draus ziehen?
Na da kann man schon Schlüsse daraus ziehen, aber die sind nicht exakt genug.
Unsere Modelle müssen ohnehin mit so vielen Unsicherheiten arbeiten,
dass wir da, wo wir es genauer machen können, natürlich versuchen, es so genau wie möglich zu machen.
Verstehe.
Und über die Länge, da gibt es dann halt bestimmte Orte, je weiter der nach Osten geht, desto schlechter wächst er,
weil der physiologische Stress mit weniger Salzgehalt größer ist, deswegen wächst der schlechter.
Da kann man dann einen 30 cm langen Dorsch haben, der vielleicht drei Jahre alt ist,
während ein 30 cm langer Dorsch in der westlichen Ostsee wahrscheinlich ein zweijähriger ist.
Und diese Unsicherheit versuchen wir zu beseitigen, indem wir möglichst genau gucken, wie alt die sind.
Das ist die Beprobung der Anlandung, die so über den Daumen vielleicht 80%
oder der kommerziellen Fischerei, die ungefähr 80% unserer Daten ausmacht.
Wir schicken auch Beprober mit auf die Fahrzeuge, denn manchmal landet was über Bord, was wir auch gerne wissen wollen und so weiter.
Das machen dann die Beobachter an Bord.
Nun führt der Fischer ja ein kommerzielles Unternehmen, der will Geld verdienen,
und fischt deswegen da, wo er besonders hohe Dichten von Fisch hat,
um mit möglichst wenig Aufwand von Produktionsmitteln möglichst viel Fisch zu fangen.
Uns interessiert aber natürlich auch, wie sieht es woanders aus, wo der Fischer nicht hinkommt?
Wir wollen also gerne wissen, wie weit ist der ganze Bestand verbreitet
und in welchem Zustand ist er woanders als da, wo es diese befischbaren Konzentrationen gibt?
Wir wollen außerdem wissen, wieviel Nachwuchs kommt nach?
Denn gerade bei sehr intensiv genutzten Fischbeständen spielt die Anzahl der Jungtiere die entscheidende Rolle für die Vorhersage der Fangmöglichkeiten im nächsten Jahr.
Sind denn diese Orte, wo jetzt viele Fische sind, konstant oder ändern die sich nicht auch?
Die ändern sich leider dauernd, deswegen muss man im Grunde das gesamte Gebiet abdecken.
Und die ändern sich zum Teil regelmäßig.
Also wir wissen, zu einer bestimmten Jahreszeit sitzen in aller Regel die großen Fische hier,
die großen Dorsche sitzen im ersten Quartal in den tiefen Becken der Ostsee, weil sie sich da zum Laichen vorbereiten oder zum Laichen versammeln.
Die jungen Tieren sitzen eher im Flachwasser, um den großen Tieren zu entgehen,
weil die großen Tiere die jungen Tiere sonst fressen würden, das macht also ökologische natürlich irgendwie Sinn, dass die sich aus dem Weg gehen.
Aber es gibt völlig unterschiedliche Fressplätze, zu verschiedenen Zeiten im Jahr sitzen die an unterschiedlichen Stellen.
Die fressen an unterschiedlichen Stellen, wo sie Laichen sind wieder andere Plätze und so weiter.
Das muss man also wissen, bevor man rausfährt und einfach mal irgendwie ein Netz reinhält und sagt,
Mensch alles voll mit Fisch, das funktioniert nicht so gut.
Und das versuchen wir mit den Forschungsschiffen, dafür brauchen wir diese hochspezialisierten Forschungsschiffe,
die dann jedes von den dreien 260-270 Tage im Jahr auf See sind.
Und mit denen machen wir genau das, wir fangen Jungtiere, die ein Fischer in der Regel vermeiden möchte,
einfach weil sie nicht gutes Geld bringen und einfach auch zu wenig sind sozusagen.
Das wollen wir aber wissen, wieviele Jungtiere gibt es?
Wir wollen die Umweltbedingungen mit erfassen, die den Fischer in der Regel erst mal nicht interessieren.
Entweder er kennt sie aus alter Erfahrung, aber der fängt jetzt nicht an,
Wassertemperatur und Salzgehalt und Sauerstoffgehalt zu messen, das machen wir dann.
Und wir wollen eben auch in den Gebieten fischen und wissen, was da los ist, in denen ein Fischer nicht fischt,
weil der von Vornherein davon ausgeht, da habe ich noch nie was gefangen, da ist auch weiter nichts.
Auch das müssen wir immer verifizieren.
Und dafür haben wir unsere eigenen Forschungsschiffe.
Diese Daten, die sogenannten Fischereiabhängigen, also die aus der kommerziellen Fischerei,
und die fischereiunabhängigen Daten, die wir selber erhoben haben, führen wir dann zusammen
und stecken sie in ein Modell, ein mathematisches Modell, was aus dem Ist-Zustand rückrechnet,
in welchem Zustand die Fische vor einem Jahr, vor zwei Jahren, vor drei Jahren gewesen sein müssen.
Das nennen wir die Rückschau, das ist also was, was längst vergangen ist.
Wir versuchen nur zu analysieren, wieviel Fisch gab es am 31.12. des letzten Jahres?
Und wenn das alles gut klappt und die Daten aus der kommerziellen Fischerei und der Forschungsfischerei gut übereinstimmen
und keine großen Fehler angezeigt werden oder große Unsicherheiten,
dann drehen wir uns um und machen das, was die Meteorologen auch machen,
wir versuchen eine Vorhersage zu rechnen.
Und anders als die Meteorologen, die relativ kurze Vorhersagezeiträume haben,
also anhand der Wetterdaten, die sie in den letzten zwei Monaten genommen haben, jetzt vorhersagen sollen, wie das Wetter morgen und übermorgen ist
und dann so ab nächste Woche wird es schon sehr unsicher, da geht diese Schere in der Tagesschau schon sehr weit auseinander
und man könnte irgendeine Temperatur zwischen 10 und 35 Grad haben, das ist dann ziemlich sinnlos.
Das ist bei uns ganz ähnlich, nur unsere Vorhersagezeiträume sind viel länger.
Denn wir treffen uns im Jahr 2018, um die Bestandsberechnung durchzuführen,
aber für 2018 sind die Quoten ja schon festgesetzt, die Fangmengen ja schon begrenzt.
Das heißt, die Politik will jetzt von uns wissen, wie viel man 2019 fangen kann.
Dazu kommt, dass wir gar nicht genau wissen, was denn am 01.01.2018 los war.
Der Meteorologe kann nach oben gucken oder seine vielen Wetterdatenschreiber auswerten,
wir müssen im Gruden das berechnen und Schlüsse ziehen darauf, in welchem Zustand dieser Fischbestand war.
Und um das noch schlimmer zu machen haben wir ein Jahr, nämlich das Zwischenjahr,
dieses Jahr 2018, in dem zwar gefischt wird, was aber noch nicht vorbei ist.
so dass wir gar nicht wissen, was in dem Jahr passiert.
Und natürlich hat das aktuelle Jahr den größten Einfluss auf den Zustand der Fischbestände.
Wir machen da das, was alle Forscher im Grunde machen, wenn man keine Daten hat tut man so,
als wenn alles stabil weiterginge.
Wenn es einen Trend gibt, dann setzen wir den Trend fort.
Wenn es keinen Trend gibt, dann sagen wir, es ist alles genau wie in den fünf Jahren zuvor.
Aber es gibt keinerlei Garantie dafür, dass das so ist.
Und ein sehr prominentes Beispiel ist der Regierungswechsel in Polen 2006/07,
damals als die Kaczynski-Regierung durch die Tusk-Regierung abgelöst wurde,
bis dahin hat die polnische Fischerei, das haben die selber so angegeben,
ungefähr das doppelte dessen an Dorsch gefischt, was sie durften.
Waren damals gerade der Europäischen Union beigetreten, da hat man die Augen zugedrückt,
aber wir wussten im Grunde alle, da wird viel mehr Dorsch entnommen als zugelassen.
Und das haben wir fortgeschrieben für das Zwischenjahr 2007 mit der neuen Regierung,
die gesagt hat, wir sind Europäer, wir halten uns selbstverständlich auch an die europäischen Regeln,
wurde diese illegale Überfischung von einem Jahr aufs andere beendet
und die polnische Regierung hat sogar mit der EU über Rückzahlungsmodalitäten verhandelt.
Also wie können wir den Schaden, den wir angerichtet haben, tatsächlich auch wieder zurückbezahlen?
Das war für uns Meeresbiologen…
Unerwartet.
… erst mal unerwartet.
Und wenn man in einem Jahr viel mehr fischt, 30-40% mehr Fisch im Wasser lässt als wir das vorhergesagt haben,
dann kann sich so ein Bestand natürlich auch sehr schnell erholen.
Von daher rührt dieser Zwist, dass die Fischerei gesagt hat, ihr habt über Jahre gesagt,
der Bestand kann sich nicht erholen und nun erholt er sich doch, was seid denn ihr für Vorhersager?
Und wir sagen dann immer, naja wir haben immer gesagt, der Bestand wird sich nicht mit großer Sicherheit erholen, wenn es so weitergeht,
aber wenn irgendein wesentlicher Faktor geändert wird, wie, man fischt 30% weniger,
weil man die illegale Überfischung von 40% auf 2% reduziert durch einen Regierungswechsel in Polen,
dann hat das natürlich sehr positive Auswirkungen auf die Fischbestände.
Also stellen Sie sich vor, von uns wird verlangt, was von einem Meteorologen verlangt würde,
wenn man dem sagt, ich gebe dir Daten aus den letzten 2-3 Monaten, aber mit einer großen Unschärfe
und ich verbinde dir für die letzte Woche die Augen, aber du musst trotzdem sicher sagen,
wie nächstes Jahr das Wetter an Weihnachten wird.
Das ist fast unmöglich.
Und man kann da schon was machen, aber man muss immer wieder sagen,
die Unsicherheiten sind erheblich.
Unser Metier ist eine sehr unsichere Art der Forschung, es ist halt keine Physik, die exakt ist,
sondern es ist Biologie, es ist mit großen Unsicherheiten behaftet, die muss man kommunizieren.
Wir bemühen uns, das zu kommunizieren.
Ein gutes Management nimmt das auf und versteht, dass da eine gewisse Unsicherheit drin ist.
Das kann man uns im Ernst nicht vorwerfen, wir tun was wir können, um es präziser zu machen,
aber es wird immer unsicher bleiben.
Und wenn wir so in die Größenordnung 10-15% Unsicherheit kommen, dann ist das schon relativ gut.
Im Prinzip ist das ja so gelebte Chaostheorie.
Da kommen einfach viele Faktoren rein, die sich gar nicht so genau festlegen lassen.
Dazu kommt dann sicherlich auch noch so der Einfluss es Klimawandels.
Trotz alledem denke ich mir, müsste ja dann eigentlich über die Jahre sich bestimmte Verfahren dann auch bewährt haben
oder weniger bewährt haben, so dass diese Modelle auch laufend angepasst werden?
Ganz genau, das passiert immer wieder.
Wir haben inzwischen regelmäßige Zyklen, alle 3-5 Jahre überprüfen wir unsere Modelle,
stellen alles auf den Prüfstand, alle Eingangsdaten in die Berechnung, das Berechnungsmodell selber,
die Settings, also die Stellschrauben, die wir in diesen Modellen natürlich immer haben
und fangen im Grunde nochmal von vorne an, immer in der Hoffnung, dass wir was verbessern.
Das bedeutet leider für die Fischerei und die Politik, dass es alle 3-5 Jahre auch zu erheblichen Änderungen in unserer Wahrnehmung eines Bestandes kommen kann.
Einfach nur, weil unsere Modelle sich ändern.
Und das ist wieder wahnsinnig schwer zu kommunizieren.
Also man kann inzwischen vergleichsweise leicht, wir können vergleichsweise leicht kommunizieren,
hier hat, wie beim westlichen Dorsch, beim Dorsch der westlichen Ostsee,
über Jahre eine Überfischung stattgefunden, das wissen wir auch seit 8-10 Jahren,
seit 7 Jahren empfehlen wir dringend, die Fangmengen deutlich stärker zu senken als sie gesenkt wurden.
Da gibt es viele Gründe, warum das nicht gemacht wurde, das ist auch alles verständlich, aber am Ende ist der Bestand kollabiert.
Das kann man ableiten.
Viel schwieriger ist es zu sagen, der Heringsbestand der westlichen Ostsee, dem geht es zurzeit gar nicht gut,
wir haben aber noch vorletztes Jahr gedacht, dass es ihm gut ginge und wir haben das Modell geändert,
wir haben die Stellschrauben geändert und sind jetzt der Ansicht, es geht ihm nicht gut.
Da ist kein einziger Fisch mehr gefangen worden, letztlich ist es nur unsere Wahrnehmung des Bestandes.
Und das an den Mann zu bringen, der Fischerei und der Politik zu erklären, ist deutlich schwieriger.
Kann ich mir vorstellen, das hat so ein bisschen was von Weissagung.
Genau, und wir bemühen uns halt, nicht dieses Weißkittel oder Papstwahl und Rauch kommt raus
und entweder ihr nehmt das, weil es sind die besten Daten, die ihr kriegen könnt oder ihr lasst es bleiben, aber wir erklären es nicht,
sondern wir versuchen, es so transparent wie möglich zu machen.
Wir beteiligen die Fischerei immer wieder, gerade bei diesen fundamentalen Änderungen.
Wir laden sie immer wieder ein, eigene Daten mitzubringen, die wir dann gemeinsam mit ihnen analysieren und das funktioniert auch gut.
Und wenn es erst mal nur ist, dass die Fischerei Verständnis entwickelt für die Schwierigkeiten, die wir haben,
zu einer möglichst exakten Aussage über den Fischbestand zu kommen.
Idealerweise sieht die Fischerei und auch die Politik dann auch ein, wofür das alles nützlich ist.
Warum wir so was brauchen und warum der Verweis auf die Unsicherheit unserer Ergebnisse am Ende nicht dazu dienen kann,
die Fischereiforschung insgesamt zu diskreditieren und dann zu sagen, das brauchen wir eigentlich alles nicht.
Wenn ihr 20-30% Unsicherheit habt, dann brauchen wir es nicht.
Doch wir brauchen es trotzdem, weil die andere Option ist, es gar nicht zu managen
und dann wie gesagt kann man langfristig nur ungefähr 10-15% der Ressource nutzen.
Ich meine, hier kann man ja wirklich mal betonen, dass hier alle im selben Boot sitzen.
Diesmal passt der Begriff dann auch wirklich richtig gut.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass, wie in so vielen Bereichen, hier auch technologisch sich einiges dreht?
Also andere Messmethoden, generelle andere Ansätze.
Ich frage mich gerade, ob hier auch es in irgendeiner Form Unterstützung aus dem All geben kann, durch genauere Erdbeobachtung.
Meeresströme werden ja sehr viel genauer analysiert, Temperaturmessung, andere Aspekte, Algenbildung.
Das sind ja alles Dinge, die mittlerweile auch aus dem Weltall ganz gut beobachtet werden kann.
Gibt es da auch schon Berührungspunkte mit der ESA zum Beispiel hier, um neue Erkenntnisse zu gewinnen?
Klar die gibt es, was immer wir an Daten bekommen können, sammeln wir natürlich.
Also wir sammeln nicht nur immer friedlich vor uns hin und haben Scheuklappen, was alle anderen Disziplinen angeht,
sondern wo immer Daten, die für uns relevant sein könnten, gesammelt werden, gucken wir uns das auch an.
Das große Problem bei der Satelliten-, also bei der Fernerkundung, ist im Grunde,
dass die Eindringtiefe zu flach ist.
Alles, was wir aus den Satelliten sehen, sind Oberflächendaten.
In sehr sehr günstigen Fällen, also ganz klares Wasser zum Beispiel, ist die Eindringtiefe vielleicht 30 Meter oder so was.
Aber wenn man sich vorstellt, dass die Ostsee alleine, also das Bornholm-Becken,
wo die meisten Dorsche rumschwimmen, ist so 60-80 Meter tief, im offenen Ozean ist das alles noch viel tiefer,
der Wasserkörper darunter ist für die Fischerei eigentlich der spannend,
und an der Oberfläche gibt es so einzelne Bestände, Makrelen zum Beispiel, die in der Nähe der Oberfläche wohnen,
aber insgesamt …
Na gut, ich bin jetzt nicht davon ausgegangen, dass man mit dem Satelliten die Fische zählen kann,
aber sozusagen weitere Parameter in die Gesamtrechnung mit einfließen zu lassen.
Genau, aber auch da habe ich dann die Oberflächentemperatur.
Mich interessiert aber die Insitu-Temperatur, also die Temperatur auf der Fangtiefe, da wo die Fische leben.
Und da gibt die Oberflächentemperatur einen guten Hinweis oder, was weiß ich,
die Entwicklung von Blaualgenblüten, die dann toxisch sein können, das kann man an der Oberfläche sehen
und das hat natürlich eine Auswirkung auch auf den Wasserkörper darunter,
aber letztlich kann ich dann nur mutmaßen, wie genau die Temperatur am Meeresboden war, wo die meisten Fische dann leben.
Was sind denn andere Ansätze zur neuen Datenerhebung?
Also gibt es Technologien, die jetzt einen größeren Impact haben?
Die gibt es, also wenn wir mal 20-30 Jahre in die Zukunft gucken, dann stellen wir fest,
dass diese Fahrzeuge, die Schiffe, die Forschungsschiffe, die wir benutzen, extrem teuer sind,
wir brauchen die wie gesagt als Plattform, aber das größte Schiff, was wir gerade ersetzen,
die Walter-Herwig, sozusagen der Stolz unserer Forschungsflotte kommt jetzt in die Jahre,
wird demnächst 30 Jahre alt und wird dann ausgemustert und durch einen Neubau ersetzt.
Und dieser Neubau kostet tatsächlich zwischen 80 und 100 Millionen Euro.
Da kann man, mein Institut hier hat 6 Millionen Euro gekostet.
Wenn man das vergleicht und die Lebensdauer des Instituts ist mit Sicherheit länger als die eines Forschungsschiffes,
was vielleicht so 30-35 Jahre alt wird.
Das bemühen wir uns vor allen Dingen kosteneffizienter zu machen.
Personal ist sehr teuer, gut ausgebildetes Personal ist sehr teuer.
Und da kann man mit ferngesteuerten oder sogar teilautonomen Vehikeln oder Wasservehikeln sicher einiges machen.
Also eine Vorstellung ist, dass wir unsere Akustik-Serways, wo wir versuchen,
mit Schallwellen kleine Schwarmfische aufzuspüren, weil die Beprobungsdichte muss sehr groß sein,
weil die sich in Schwärmen ballen und wenn man einen Schwarm verpasst,
dann denkt man, das Meer wäre leer, dabei war der Schwarm direkt daneben.
Wenn man einen Schwarm erwischt, denkt man, man könnte trockenen Fußes nach Schweden laufen,
dabei war das nur eine Momentaufnahme.
Das heißt, wir müssen da eine sehr große Beprobungsdichte haben und das kann man mit Schiffen nur gemeinsam machen.
So machen wir es bisher und sehr aufwendig machen über viele Wochen.
Man könnte sich aber vorstellen, dass dieses Schiff einfach als Basis für eine Flotte von Unterwasserrobotern dient,
von Unterwasserdrohnen sozusagen, die dann genau diese akustischen Messungen entweder in einem viel größeren Bereich gleichzeitig
oder mit viel höherer Auflösung betreiben und dann abends wieder auf das Forschungsschiff zurückkommen, aufgeladen werden,
die Daten werden runtergesogen sozusagen, gleich verarbeitet, ich denke da geht es hin.
Da gibt es die ersten Vorstellungen dazu, da gibt es die ersten fast anwendbaren Geräte,
die sind alle im Moment noch so teuer, dass sich das kaum jemand leisten kann,
aber früher oder später wird das so sein.
Da tut sich ja gerade eine Menge.
Und vor allem, die können sich ja im Prinzip auch selber aufladen, also ich habe auch schon verschiedene Beispiel von so Hochseedrohnen gesehen,
die halt Strömungen etc., Meerestemperatur messen, die im Prinzip autark sind.
Also die einfach aufsteigen, so lange an der Sonne bleiben, bis sie ihre Akkus wieder geladen haben,
sich dann absenken, ihre Messungen machen etc..
Also das ist sozusagen ein Trend, der jetzt absehbar ist.
Das klingt ja eigentlich recht verheißungsvoll.
Das könnte ja bedeuten, dass dieses Problem der Auflösung oder eben auch der Frequenz oder eben beides
signifikant sich ändern könnte.
Ja, es wird scher präziser, wie im Grunde seit 100 Jahren, seitdem wir das mit unseren internationalen Partnern betreiben.
Da war am Anfang der Schwerpunkt darauf, die Methoden zu harmonisieren, damit wir wirklich alle das gleiche machen.
Und das tun wir.
Jetzt ist der Schwerpunkt auf der technologischen Weiterentwicklung.
Dennoch werden wir auch durch Unterwasserdrohnen am Ende nicht wissen,
in welchem Ernährungszustand dieser oder jener Dorschbestand war.
Also auch dafür werden wir die Fische einfach weiter anfassen müssen.
Ja klar.
Und um die anzufassen, müssen wir sie vorher fangen und das werden Drohnen erst mal nicht für uns tun.
Wer weiß?
Wer weiß, also es bleibt dabei, wir werden solche Forschungsplattformen brauchen,
aber wir werden sie wahrscheinlicher viel sinnvoller und viel kostengünstiger einsetzen können.
Und können dann mehr Programme zur gleichen Zeit als wir es zurzeit können.
Das ist sozusagen die Forschungsseite, die Datenerhebungsseite aus der Forschung.
Es gibt aber natürlich auch die Datenerhebungsseite aus der kommerziellen Fischerei.
Und ich hatte schon gesagt, 80% der Daten kommen aus der kommerziellen Fischerei,
und da wissen wir von den großen Fahrzeugen sehr sehr gut Bescheid,
weil wir da Beobachter an Bord haben oder die lückenlos mit Satelliten überwacht werden,
wir wissen aber von den kleinen Fahrzeugen, also diesen Booten zwischen 5 und 8 Metern, sagen wir mal,
und aus der Nebenerwerbsfischerei und so weiter, da wissen wir tatsächlich relativ wenig.
Die meisten Fahrzeuge sind zu klein, um Beobachter mitnehmen zu können,
da können wir also nur nebenherfahren.
Das reicht aber nicht, weil wir keine flächendeckende Abdeckung hinbekommen.
Und auch da sitzen wir dran und haben im letzten Jahr eine Smartphone-Application entwickelt,
um die Fischer in die Lage zu versetzen, ihre genauen Fangpositionen anzugeben.
Und das so einfach wie möglich, wir wollen die ja nicht irgendwie knechten,
und natürlich beschweren die sich zurecht, dass es auf einem schaukelnden Boot,
wenn es nass ist und 1 Grad kalt oder so was, dann ist es schon schwierig, ein Smartphone zu bedienen.
Auch da arbeiten wir dran, dass man irgendwelche Bluetoothknöpfe hat, auf die man nur drauf haut,
die man irgendwo ans Ruderhaus klebt und dann haut man drauf und dann spielt sich das automatisch durch das Menü durch
und sagt halt, einmal drauf hauen ist Netz setzen, zweimal draufhauen ist Ende Netz setzen oder irgendwie so was.
Am Ende wird es in den nächsten paar Jahren technische Entwicklungen geben,
die uns ermöglichen, auch die Daten aus der kommerziellen Fischerei viel verlässlicher zu erheben
und das eben möglichst flächendeckend.
Nicht nur zum Wohle unserer Bestandsberechnung, was am Ende auch zum Wohle der Fischerei ist,
weil unsere Daten verlässlicher werden, sondern auch direkt zum Wohl der Fischerei,
weil wir am Ende die Fischerei nachhaltiger gestalten können.
Wenn wir also wissen, in der kleinen Stellnetzfischerei gibt es Probleme mit Seevogelbeifängen,
dann können wir versuchen, durch bessere Daten genau rauszukriegen,
wo ist denn die Überlappung, das Risiko am größten.
Und statt dann zu sagen, wie es einige Umweltverbände fordern, die Stellnetzfischerei sollte aus der Ostsee ganz ausgeschlossen werden,
weil wir es nicht akzeptabel finden, dass da so viele Enten oder meinetwegen auch Schweinswale oder so was drin landen,
könnte man das viel genauer fassen und sagen, zu dieser Zeit solltet ihr dort nicht fischen
oder eine alternative Fangtechnik verwenden, aber zu anderen Zeiten ist es gar nicht gefährlich,
weil da so gut wie keine Enten in euren Netzen landen.
Um das bestimmen zu können, brauchen wir viel mehr und viel besser Daten,
und die versuchen wir zu erheben.
Da kommt uns übrigens die aktuelle Datenschutzrichtlinie, die europäische, in die Quere,
weil auch das natürlich im Grunde personenbezogene Daten sind, die nicht für wissenschaftliche Zwecke,
sondern höchstens für Kontrollzwecke erhoben werden und wir haben große Probleme,
an diese Daten ranzukommen.
Also eigentlich müssen wir jeden einzelnen Fischer fragen, ob der damit einverstanden wäre, dass wir die Daten nutzen.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja dann auch eine einmalige Geschichte oder?
Die Frage bei der Fischerei?
Na wir finden erst mal kaum Fischer, die sagen, jaja macht mal,
die einsehen, dass es zu ihrem Wohl ist unmittelbar.
Das ist also eine heiße Diskussion.
Und dann kommt die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte und sagt, nein nein,
Daten, die für Kontrollzwecke erhoben sind, können Sie leider nicht für wissenschaftliche Zwecke verwenden.
Andererseits möchte unser auftragegebendes Ministerium für die Ausweisung von Schutzgebieten
oder für die Datenlieferung an die Helsinki-Konvention oder so was halt genau wissen,
wo sich wieviele Fahrzeuge aufhalten, das kriegen wir wieder nur über diese Daten raus.
Ja, die Datenschutzgrundverordnung, das wird sicherlich noch ein interessanter Prallbock der Realitäten werden im diesem Jahr,
ich denke, das ist auch jedem klar, dass hier der erste Wurf sicherlich noch nicht überall perfekt sitzt.
Aber auch um solche Fragen muss man sich ja letzten Endes kümmern.
Was mir noch einfiel, es gibt ja auch so, wie heißt das, Rückwürfe, also wenn Fische gefangen werden,
aber auch wieder zurück ins Meer gehen, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, also was sind da die Motivationen,
das überhaupt zu tun und was muss man darüber wissen?
Da gibt es ganz verschiedene Motivationen.
In erster Näherung ist alles, was der Fischer für wertlos hält, geht wieder über Bord
oder ging wenigstens bisher wieder über Bord.
Dann gibt es aber eine Reihe von Regeln, die den Fischer zwingen, Fische über Bord zu schmeißen,
selbst wenn er für den Fischer wertvoll ist.
Bisher war es also so, dass die Quoten, die Fischereiquoten, die Fangmengenbegrenzung gar keine Fangmengenbegrenzung,
sondern Anlandemengenbegrenzungen waren.
Das heißt, der Fischer konnte weiter fischen, wenn er die Quote für eine Art aber ausgeschöpft hatte,
die ihm zugewiesene Quote, durfte er den Fisch nicht mehr anlanden und musste ihn dann über Bord schmeißen.
Dadurch wurde relativ viel Fisch vernichtet, der theoretisch anlande- und auch verzehrfähig war.
Weil die Fische dann schon sterben, wenn sie gefangen werden.
Das ist natürlich ein Irrsinn
Genau, und das ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Es gibt Fische, die diesen Vorgang, also den Fang- und Sortiervorgang, vergleichsweise gut überleben,
aber die allermeisten Fische überleben den eben nicht, wenn die vier Stunden in einem Netz waren
und mit ihren Genossen zusammen in dem Netz gedrückt wurden und dann sagen wir mal noch 20 Minuten an der Luft getrocknet sind,
bis sie verarbeitet wurden, dann sind die Überlebenschancen gleich 0.
Es gibt bestimmte Fangtechniken, bei denen das anders ist, wenn die in großen Reusen gefangen werden,
bleiben die lebend, oder beim Angeln sind die Überlebensraten relativ groß, das wissen wir,
aber in der kommerziellen Fischerei, egal ob in der Stellnetzfischerei oder in der Schleppnetzfischerei,
sind die Überlebensraten sehr sehr gering.
Das hat Gesetzgeber dazu bewogen, im Rahmen der letzten Reform der gemeinsamen europäischen Fischereipolitik,
ein sogenanntes Anlandegebot vorzusehen.
Das heißt, alle quotierten Arten, die gefangen wurden, müssen mit an Land gebracht werden.
Das alleine wäre gar nicht nötig gewesen, man hätte es auch einfach dokumentieren können,
aber wichtig ist, sie müssen auf die Quote angerechnet werden,
und wenn die Quote ausgeschöpft ist, darf das Fahrzeug nicht mehr fahren.
Anders als bisher, wo der immer weiter fahren konnte, und einfach weiter gefischt hat,
und dann die Fische, für die er noch Quote hatte, raussortiert hat und die anderen über Bord geschmissen hat,
ist jetzt die Fischerei zu Ende, wenn man die erste Quote ausgeschöpft hat.
Aber wie kann man denn die Fischer daran hindern, das einfach weiterhin zu tun?
Das genau ist die gute Frage, und leider hat der Gesetzgeber an dieser Stelle wieder ein Gesetz erlassen
ohne sich um die Implementierung, also die Umsetzung, zu kümmern.
Und das erweist sich jetzt als riesiger Nachteil, weil es tatsächlich fast keine Möglichkeit gibt,
der Fischerei gerichtsfest nachzuweisen, wenn sie doch weiter "discarded"
Und wir wissen, dass es einzelne Fischereien gibt, auch in der Ostsee,
wo die Discard-Raten sogar gestiegen sind nach Einführungen des Discard Bans, des Anlandeverbotes.
Das ist natürlich im Grunde unhaltbar, denn die Ehrlichen sind an dieser Stelle die Gelackmeierten.
Ja, was könnte man denn tun?
Das, was man aus unserer Sicht tun könnte, wäre, für alle die gleichen Regeln erlassen und die lückenlos überwachen,
das kann man inzwischen mit elektronischen Möglichkeiten machen.
Das ist so dieses Stichwort, Kameras an Bord.
Ich kann gut verstehen, dass Fischer der Meinung sind, wir wollen nicht überwacht werden,
das will keiner von uns gerne, aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
der Fischer nutzt eine Ressource, die uns, der Gesellschaft, gehört,
er zahlt dafür nicht, er bekommt sie von uns zur Verfügung gestellt,
da können wir doch erwarten, dass er die von uns erlassenen Regeln einhält.
Und wenn er das möglicherweise nicht tut, dann muss man es besser kontrollieren.
Und was mir vorschwebt, ist, dass man sagt, wir wissen, in dieser Fischerei gibt es bis zu 20% Rückwürfe,
um auf der sicheren Seite zu sein, ziehen wir das ab von der Quote,
das heißt, der Fischer bekommt nur 80% seiner Quote, wenn er die zusätzlichen 20% haben möchte,
dann müsste er sich Kameras an Bord installieren oder elektronisches Monitoring installieren,
dann kann er die zusätzlichen 20% auch nutzen, hat einen Anreiz.
Aber wir adressieren auch, dass der Fischer sagt, ich will das nicht.
Kein Problem, wenn er das nicht will, dann fischt er halt bloß 80% der bisherigen Quote.
Jetzt sind wir ja im Prinzip bei diesem Thema von der Datenerfassung schon zum eigentlichen Management gekommen.
Die Frage, wie kann man generell Anreize schaffen, um die ganze Fischerei in einer Art und Weise ablaufen zu lassen,
dass es eben für alle Beteiligten, also die Gesellschaft, die Umwelt, die Fische – gut, die Fische sind immer ein bisschen die Gelackmeierten -
aber im Prinzip das ganze System rund zu machen.
Das war jetzt so ein Beispiel, was sind denn so die anderen Politiken, auf die Sie so drängen als Institut?
Ja wir fangen erst mal an mit der Analyse, wie läuft es bisher?
Was machen wir bisher, damit es gut läuft?
Wo läuft es schlecht, was könnten wir tun, um den Problemen abzuhelfen?
Und wir sehen einfach, es gibt die europäische gemeinsame Fischereipolitik seit vielen Jahrzehnten,
und im Grunde läuft das immer gleich ab.
Wir als Eigentümer der Ressource erlassen eine Regel, die Regel wird von Schreibtischtätern,
wie wir natürlich letztlich auch sind, aber dann auch von den viel gescholtenen Bürokraten in Brüssel erlassen,
und der Fischer hat viel Zeit, sich darum zu kümmern, wie man die Regeln möglichst weit auslegt
bzw. wie man sie rechtskonform oder nicht rechtskonform umgeht.
Das, was wirklich fehlt, ist eine fundamentale Änderung, die immer Auge hat,
wir müssen die richtigen Anreize schaffen.
Wir brauchen im Grunde viel weniger Regeln, denn zurzeit kommt immer auf jede Regel,
die nicht funktioniert hat, eine neue Regel drauf, statt dass man die alte Regel abschafft.
Wir brauchen weniger neue Regeln, wir brauchen überhaupt aus unserer Sicht viel weniger Regeln
und stattdessen ein vernünftiges gut durchdachtes Anreizsystem.
Dann käme man mit sehr wenigen klaren Regeln mit möglichst wenig Ausnahmen klar.
Also zum Beispiel mit einer Fangmengenbegrenzung, die dann aber auch durchgehalten werden muss.
Da kann es keine Ausnahmen davon geben.
Das heißt, dann alles, was ich gefangen habe, muss auch mit, muss auf die Quote angerechnet werden.
Ich finde sogar, Fische, die nicht quotiert sind, sollten darauf angerechnet werden auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise,
denn da ist das Discarden nach wie vor möglich.
Aber dafür kann man all diese Spezialregeln, die inzwischen den Aufbau von Netzen,
die Anzahl der Maschen im Umfang des letzten Teils des Netzes und so weiter regulieren,
wenn ein Fischer sein Netz reparieren muss, dann gibt es Vorschriften, wie er das reparieren muss.
Ich kann verstehen, dass der Fischer am Ende sagt, wir stehen erstens immer mit einem Bein im Gefängnis
und wer soll das überhaupt alles im Kopf oder auf Papier haben?
Man müsste im Grunde Aktenordner mit an Bord nehmen, um da nachzugucken,
ob man sich noch regelkonform verhält.
Das würden wir gerne ändern.
Und dazu gehört, dass wir verstehen müssen, wie Fischer genau ticken.
Denn am Ende des Tages managen wir kein Fischbestände.
Der Biologie ist ziemlich egal, was wir hier so machen.
Die Fischbestände werden größer und kleiner je nach Umweltbedingungen und Fischereidruck.
Sondern wir managen menschliches Verhalten, in diesem Fall das Verhalten des Fischers.
Und eigentlich müsste die Intension dahingehen, Gesetze zu erlassen, deren Einhaltung im Interesse des Fischers ist.
Das erfordert ein ganz anderes Denken und das wird dann sehr sehr schwierig,
wenn man zum Beispiel mit Inspektoren verhandelt, die halt wissen wie es läuft normalerweise,
wie es in den letzten 45 Jahren gelaufen ist und die sagen,
ja aber das kann man nicht gerichtsfest nachweisen.
Und so was wie Beweislastumkehr, das ist so ein bisschen so mein Steckenpferd.
Ich bin der Meinung, wenn ein Fischer die von uns besessene Ressource benutzt,
dann könnten wir von ihm auch verlangen, dass er uns nachweist, dass er sich an die Regeln hält,
statt das andersrum zu machen.
Wir müssen immer gerichtsfest nachweisen, dass der Fischer sich an die Regeln hält.
Das ist in unserem Rechtssystem ganz schwierig durchzusetzen.
Aber auch dafür gibt es Beispiele.
Wenn einer von uns tankt an der Tankstelle, ist der sofort unter Generalverdacht,
der wird immer gefilmt, damit man, wenn er abhaut, ohne zu bezahlen, ihn verfolgen kann.
In dem Moment, wo er vernünftig bezahlt hat, wird das Band wieder gelöscht.
Kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten, ob das eine gute Methode ist,
Tankkunden unter Generalverdacht zu setzen, aber jeder von uns ist damit einverstanden,
am Anfang, an der Grenze der Tankstelle steht, Achtung hier wirst du gefilmt,
wenn du das nicht möchtest, tank doch woanders, sieh doch zu, wo du deinen Sprit her kriegst.
Und so was in der Art könnte man natürlich in der Fischerei auch machen.
Da muss man alle möglichen Randbedingungen beachten, wir wollen nicht den Fischer filmen,
sondern wir wollen die Fische filmen und so weiter, aber generell könnte man es der Fischerei überlassen,
wie sie ihre Fischerei möglichst, wie sie ihre Aktivität möglichst nachhaltig gestaltet,
solange wir nur die Rahmenbedingungen festsetzen und sagen, du fischt von dieser Art nicht mehr als das und das
und es ist deine Sache, uns nachzuweisen, wie du das machst.
Und vor allem dann halt mit so einem angeschlossenen Belohnungssystem, umso mehr Konformität man zu diesen Datenerhebungen etc. macht,
umso mehr extra bekommt man, um diese, vorhin fiel die Zahl, 20 %, das ist vielleicht schon mal ein ganz interessanter Bereich,
um sozusagen mehr davon zu haben.
Das wäre dieses Anreizsystem, genau.
Und ich glaube daran, dass Menschen mit Anreizen viel besser funktionieren als mit Strafen,
insbesondere wenn die Strafen so wenig drakonisch sind, also im Grunde so läppisch sind,
dass man ohne weiteres durch ein illegales Verhalten einen Vorteil von einer Million Euro genießen kann,
und dann aber 10.000 Euro Bußgeld zahlt für die Verfälschung des Logbuchs oder so was,
das ist natürlich albern, das bringt keinen Fischer dazu, sich an die Regeln zu halten.
Entweder man muss die Strafen viel drakonischer machen, so wie das in Norwegen stattfindet,
da wird das Schiff dann für die ganze Saison an die Kette gelegt, das ist die eine Möglichkeit.
Ich halte es für besser, und so erziehe ich meine Kinder dann auch, auf positive Verstärkung zu setzen und zu sagen,
du wirst belohnt dafür, dass du bereit bist, mehr beizutragen, nachzuweisen,
dass du dich regelkonform verhältst.
Das haben wir getestet in der Nordsee mit einem Versuch, mit einem internationalen Experiment,
das hieß Catch-Quota-Management, wo es tatsächlich darum ging, nicht mehr die Anlandung,
sondern die Fänge zu betrachten.
Und da hat die Fischerei tatsächlich für die Nordseekabeljaufischerei 30% Zuschlag bekommen,
wenn sie sich lückenlos mit Kameras überwachen ließ.
Das hat wunderbar funktioniert.
Die berichtete Fangzusammensetzung dieser überwachten Fahrzeuge ist völlig anders,
als die Fangzusammensetzung der Fahrzeuge ohne Kamera,
was darauf hindeutet, dass egal, ob wir die auswerten oder nicht, die Bereitschaft der Fischerei,
das aufzuschreiben, was sie wirklich fängt, viel größer ist, also da gibt es Unterschiede,
was uns dann im Nachhinein auch zeigt, wie unzuverlässig tatsächlich unsere Fangstatistiken sind,
selbst bei den Fahrzeugen, von denen wir glauben, dass sie relativ gut sind.
Und das hat gut geklappt.
Die neue dänische Regierung hat diesen Versuch leider – die Dänen waren führend da –
wir waren sozusagen nur das vierte Rad am Wagen, waren nur mit wenigen Fahrzeugen beteiligt,
die neue dänische Regierung hat das leider eingestellt, was wir sehr bedauert haben,
aber Regierungen kommen und gehen und die dänische Fischerei war von diesem Experiment begeistert
und hat gesagt, das ist genau der richtige Weg, wir wollen, anders als unser Fischereiminister, im Grunde die Kameras gerne behalten.
Ja, also da könnte man sozusagen mit einem belohnungsorientierten System für alle Beteiligten eigentlich das Leben einfacher machen,
weil man erhält ja auch bessere Daten und damit noch bessere Vorhersage potenziell und dann haben ja alle was davon.
Ganz genau. Aber es erfordert eben, dass man das gesamte System, das gesamte Regelwerk einmal auf den Prüfstand stellt
und wirklich sozusagen mit dem eisernen Besen durchgeht und sagt,
diese ganzen Regeln, wo wir Fanggeräte exakt definieren, nur weil man es zufällig messen kann,
für die Nachhaltigkeit hat das im Grunde kaum eine Auswirkung.
Es geht nur darum, der Inspektor kann die Maschenweite im Steert messen.
Was weiter vorne passiert, ist egal, aber was hinten passiert, kann man messen.
Was ist Steert?
Steert ist der hinterste Teil des Netzes, da wo die Fische am Ende dann gefangen werden,
wenn sie sich zurückfallen lassen.
Und das müsste man einfach wirklich ausmisten und da wird es dann sehr schwierig.
Vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz zur Technologie, bevor wir vielleicht nochmal auch so insgesamt über die ernährungspolitischen Dimension der ganzen Geschichte diskutieren sollten.
Die Fangtechniken, die haben sich ja über die Zeit auch sehr geändert, und es klang ja anfangs schon an,
als halt sowieso noch wenig gefischt werden konnte, weil man einfach die Massen gar nicht bekommen hat,
die Dampfmaschinen nicht hatte etc., alles nicht so ausgebildet war, gab es kein Problem,
dann hat die Technologie dermaßen zugeschlagen, dass auf einmal viel zu viel möglich war.
Wie haben sich denn die Fangtechniken jetzt entwickelt, was ist da so der aktuelle Trend auch,
wie denn dieses Meer am besten bewirtschaftet werden sollte, um es möglichst nachhaltig einerseits und umweltverträglich zu machen?
Also mit Blick auf die Nachhaltigkeit kann man sagen, wenn wir es auf die Zielart beziehen,
ist eigentlich nur die Entnahmemenge wichtig.
Es spielt gar keine Rolle, ob man das mit passiven Methoden, also mit Stellnetzen oder Reusen fängt,
die Menge Fisch, oder ob man das mit Schleppnetzen fängt, am Ende kommt es nur darauf an,
wieviele Fische sterben bei diesem Vorgang, um uns als Nahrung für den Menschen zu dienen?
Es gab in den letzten, sagen wir mal, 100 Jahren so ein paar Technologiesprünge,
wo dann irgendeine neue Fischereimethode entwickelt wurde.
Ich habe vorhin schon gesagt, die Ringwadenfischerei, also die Fischerei mit Umschließungsnetzen,
die ganze Schwärme umkreisen kann, die war so effizient, dass die allermeisten kleinen Schwarmfische…
also die allermeisten großen Bestände kleiner Schwarmfische innerhalb von 6 oder 7 Jahren kollabierten.
Heringe in der Nordsee, atlanto-skandischer Hering, Makrele im Nordostatlantik.
Einer nach dem anderen wurde überfischt, bis die Fangmengen vernünftig begrenzt wurden.
Die Methode gibt es immer noch.
Die Methode ist grundsätzlich sehr gut, weil sie wenig unerwünschte Umweltauswirkungen hat.
Aber die Fangmengen muss man halt vernünftiger begrenzen.
Seitdem ist eigentlich relativ wenig passiert, muss man sagen.
Und wir sind immer wieder erstaunt, wenn wir jetzt sehen, was gibt es denn für Möglichkeiten,
neue politische Ansätze oder Managementansätze, wie das Anlandegebot umzusetzen,
wie wenig Entwicklung in die Fanggeräte gegangen ist in den letzten Jahren.
Und genau da setzen wir an.
Wir versuchen hier im Institut auch Schleppnetze zu entwickeln.
Und wir machen jetzt das gleiche auch mit der stillen Fischerei, also mit den Stellnetzen,
um die nachhaltiger zu gestalten.
Das heißt, bei den Schleppnetzen zum Beispiel, die sollen selektiver werden.
Wir wollen weniger unerwünschte Fische drin haben.
Und manchmal gibt es ganz einfache Lösungen.
Ein Schlitz in dem Zwischenteil des Netzes, wir nennen das Tunnel, an der richtigen Stelle,
mit Schwimmen oben und Gewichten unten, damit da so eine kleine linsenförmige Öffnung entsteht,
sorgt dafür, wenn man das geschickt macht und an der richtigen Stelle macht,
dass wir 80% der Plattfische aus dem Fang loswerden, aber die Dorsche zu 100% zurückhalten.
Warum gehen da nicht alle durch?
Weil die Dorsche immer versuchen, in der Mitte zu bleiben.
Die haben Sensoren, die ihnen sagen, hier ist überall Netz und die versuchen genau in der Mitte zu bleiben,
während die Plattfische immer gerne mit dem Bauch irgendwas berühren wollen.
So sind die getrimmt, so sind die gepolt.
Und deswegen bleiben die am Netzboden.
Und wenn ich an dem Netzboden so eine Öffnung mache, dann entkommen die durch diese Öffnung,
während die Dorsche in der Mitte bleiben, funktioniert wunderbar.
Da muss man mit der Größe operieren und so weiter.
Das kann jeder Fischer an seinem eigenen Netz machen, kostet vielleicht 150 Euro für Material und anderthalb Stunden Zeit.
Es ist eine minimale Änderung, der Fischer kann das auch wieder zunähen, wenn er sagt,
nein ich will aber jetzt die Plattfische fangen.
Hat aber am Ende den Vorteil, dass ich weniger Plattfische fange, wenn ich die nicht haben will
und mehr Dorsch fange und dadurch auch noch die Selektivität der Dorsche hinten,
im hintersten Teil des Netzes, verbessere, denn bisher war es so, dass die Plattfische mitgefangen wurden
und dann wie so Briefmarken die Netzöffnungen zukleisterten
und die Dorsche, für die diese Netzöffnungen optimiert waren, konnten nicht mehr entkommen,
weil vor jeder großen Masche klebte ein Plattfisch.
Das vermeide ich, wenn ich die Plattfische einen Meter weit davor loswerde.
Mahnmal sind es also wirklich so kleine Modifikationen, die bisher niemand gemacht hat,
weil es kein Interesse daran gab, weil es auch von der Fischerei kein Interesse daran gab,
plötzlich mit der Einführung des Anlandegebotes gibt es einen Anreiz,
gibt es ein Interesse der Fischerei, weil die sehen, mit der neuen Regel limitiert meine Schollenquote zum Beispiel
die Ausschöpfung der Dorschquote.
Wenn ich das nicht möchte, muss ich sehen, dass ich unter Wasser, da wo sich das sortieren lohnt,
weil über Wasser sind die eh tot, da kann ich so viel sortieren wie ich möchte,
ich muss unter Wasser sortieren.
Und das ist so eine Möglichkeit, an der wir forschen.
Und je weniger Rocket Science das ist, und eben je billiger und je einfacher flächendeckend umsetzbar, desto besser.
Deswegen haben wir da auch keine Patente drauf oder so was, sondern wir wollen,
dass es in die Fischerei Eingang findet und die Fischerei sich auch möglichst kreative Gedanken macht,
denn nochmal, die haben sehr sehr viel Zeit, sich über so was Gedanken zu machen
und wenn wir die Erfahrung der Fischer abzapfen können für solche Veränderungen,
dann ist das für alle Beteiligten besser.
Also bezieht sich hier die Neuentwicklung sozusagen nur auf Netze oder gibt es da auch noch andere technologische Bereiche,
die hier betroffen sind?
Na in der Fangtechnik bezieht sich das im Moment auf Netze, aber eben auf viele verschiedene Netze.
Also wir versuchen zum Beispiel in der Stellnetzfischerei, wo Seevogel- und Schweinswalbeifänge das große Problem sind,
diese Netze sichtbarer zu machen.
Wir versuchen einerseits, meinetwegen kleine Luftblasen mit einzuschließen oder so was,
damit die Sonarsysteme der Schweinswale die besser erkennen können.
Wir bemühen uns aber auch, die Schweinswale aufmerksam zu machen.
Das erfinden wir dann nicht selber, aber wenn es dann um den Praxistest geht,
also das Gerät heißt Pal, das ist so eine Art Pinger, der nicht einfach nur Lärm macht
und die Tiere verscheucht, sondern der einen arteigenen Laut verwendet,
um die Schweinswale aufmerksam zu machen, hier droht eine Gefahr.
In der Hoffnung, dass der Schweinswal da seine Pingrate erhöht und dann das Netz,
was wir nun im nächsten Schritt versuchen, besser sichtbar zu machen für die Sonarortung der Schweinswale,
besser erkennt und dann eben nicht in dieses Netz gerät und darin ertrinkt.
Das ist also auf vielen verschiedenen Ebenen, da gibt es noch viele offene Baustellen, die wir klären müssen,
das dauert alles ein bisschen, aber wir können immerhin schon anfangen
und das Land Schleswig-Holstein hat einem Großversuch zugestimmt und finanziert den auch,
wo genau diese Schweinswalwarngeräte, diese neuartigen, flächendeckend in ungefähr 50% der Fischerei eingesetzt werden,
in der westlichen Ostsee, in schleswig-holsteinischen Gewässern.
Das finden wir sehr sehr spannend, begleiten diesen Versuch gerne weiter,
um zu sehen, ob es vielleicht Gewöhnungseffekte gibt.
Das sind alles Sachen, die wir uns jetzt angucken müssen, aber es kommt immer wieder darauf zurück,
wenn es technologische Lösungen für solche Probleme gibt, dann ist es für die Fischerei viel einfacher umsetzbar,
als wenn man sagt, ihr müsst eine bestimmte Fischereiart ganz sein lassen.
Oder ihr dürft in großen Gebietsteilen einfach überhaupt nicht mehr fischen.
Das ist für die Fischerei immer am schlimmsten.
Im Vorgespräch klang auch an, dass Sie gerade, was diese Überzeugungsarbeit betrifft,
sich hier auch wissenschaftlich neu aufstellen.
Jetzt haben wir viel über Techniken und mathematische Dinge und Erfassung und Forschungsfahrten gesprochen,
aber Sie wollen hier sozusagen auch wissenschaftlich aufrüsten, indem Sie die Sozialwissenschaften hier mit einbringen,
was steckt da dahinter?
Na wir sind als Meeresbiologen oder Fischereibiologen natürlich überwiegend Biologen, Ökologen,
unsere Stammaufgabe ist, zu erklären, warum gibt es in einzelnen Jahren viel Nachwuchs
oder wenig Nachwuchs und so weiter.
Dann haben Sie schon angesprochen, wir haben eine große technische Abteilung,
das sind also überwiegend Ingenieure oder so was, die mit uns gut zusammenarbeiten,
aber ein ganz neues Feld ist eigentlich dieses Schaffen von Anreizsystemen.
Wo wir sehr schnell gemerkt haben, da kommen wir als Biologen einfach ans Ende unserer,
auch der, sagen wir mal, der wissenschaftlichen Herangehensweise, da wissen wir einfach nicht genug.
Wir wollen gerne wissen, was funktioniert bei Fischern?
Warum würde ein Fischer eine solche Regel anerkennen, aber eine andere nicht?
Da gibt es sehr überraschende Ergebnisse, wo Fischer sagen, ein Anreiz für uns wäre schon,
wenn der Tourist nicht in den Hafen kommt und uns morgens nach einer anstrengenden Ausfahrt,
die um 3 Uhr morgens bei 2 Grad Wassertemperatur begonnen hat, und dann sagt,
na habt ihr wieder das Meer leergefischt und das Ökosystem zerstört?
Also schon so was wäre ein Anreiz, das wollen wir gerne rauskriegen.
Und da kann man sich natürlich dauernd auch als Ökologe mit Fischern unterhalten,
aber es bleibt anekdotisch, wir wollen das gerne systematisieren und haben deswegen im Institut eine sozialwissenschaftliche Arbeitsgruppe gegründet,
die systematisch Fischer befragt zu verschiedenen Aspekten.
Das hat dann auch wieder Auswirkungen auf die Datenerhebung, weil wir an bestimmte Daten direkt gar nicht rankommen.
Zum Beispiel, wieviele Seevögel werden denn tatsächlich in der kleinen Küstenfischerei beigefangen
oder wie viele Schweinswale?
Gerade wenn es sehr sehr seltene Ereignisse sind, dann fallen die meistens unter den Tisch.
Oder es gibt einen Bias in der Erinnerung.
Der Fischer erinnert sich vielleicht da nicht dran.
Oder er erinnert sich an Schweinswale besonders gut, weil es ein so seltenes Ereignis ist,
dass er noch genau weiß, diesen Schweinswal habe ich vor 6 Jahren gefangen.
Das wollen wir alles ein bisschen systematisieren und haben deswegen eine sozialwissenschaftliche Arbeitsgruppe aufgebaut,
die wir jetzt auch mit Drittmittelprojekten und so was weiter ausbauen und die sehr sehr spannende Ergebnisse liefert.
Solche Ideen haben ja meistens so eine Vorgeschichte.
War das jetzt nur so ein Gefühl, dass das vielleicht helfen könnte oder wie kam es überhaupt zu dieser Initiative?
Na die Vorgeschichte fing eigentlich an mit den ersten Überlegungen für ein Anlandegebot in der Europäischen Union.
Und wir haben uns damals sehr schnell sozusagen auf die Seite der Befürworter geschlagen
und haben nicht gesagt, geht sowieso alles nicht, hat man noch nie probiert,
sondern wir sagten, ist ein interessanter Ansatz, aber nur dann, wenn man den Fischer auf der anderen Seite
von überflüssigem Regelwerk entlasten kann.
Am Ende ist, wie in der Europäischen Union so oft, es anders gekommen.
Auch dies ist wieder ein neues Regelwerk, was dazu kam zu dem schon bestehenden Regelwerk.
Aber in dieser Diskussion, was genau müssten wir für Regeln abschaffen,
weil sie sich als untauglich erwiesen haben oder die Fischerei knechten, belasten,
ohne dass es einen Einfluss auf die nachhaltige Nutzung der Ressourcen hat.
Und was ist wirklich neu?
Was ist was, wo der Fischer zustimmen könnte.
Da sind wir wieder bei der Geschichte, wir sitzen alle in einem Boot und wir werden solche Regeln bei der Unendlichkeit des Meeres
und der Schwierigkeit, die Fischerei lückenlos zu überwachen, werden wir nur hinbekommen,
wenn wir die Fischer mit ins Boot holen und die Fischer sagen, ja das ist eine gute Regel.
Ist vielleicht mühsam und wir wollen nicht so gerne Kameras an Bord haben, aber okay.
Wir sehen ein, um ein Levelplaying-Field, um die gleichen Bedingungen für die gesamte Fischerei zu schaffen,
ist das notwendig.
Und das war zu diesem Zeitpunkt, das ist nun auch schon 6-8 Jahre her,
war es eben anekdotisch.
Da sagt die eine Fraktion, aber ich habe das gehört und die andere Fraktion sagt,
wir haben aber was anderes gehört.
Dann gab es eine Zeit, in der wir uns sehr intensiv Gedanken gemacht haben über das Management von Anglern,
Auch das ein ganz wichtiges Thema, weil es einzelne Bestände, sehr wenige,
aber einzelne Bestände gibt, für die der Einfluss der Angelfischerei, der Freizeitfischerei sehr sehr hoch ist.
Der Dorsch der westlichen Ostsee ist ein solcher.
Inzwischen fangen die Freizeitfischer die Hälfte der Gesamtfangmenge.
Die andere Menge fangen die Berufsfischer.
Als wir das rausbekommen haben, waren wir selber sehr erstaunt, weil wir alle dachten,
das kann so viel nicht sein.
Ja.
Zeigt aber eben auch, wie wichtig die Angelfischerei ist.
Da gibt es dann viele ökonomische Gesichtspunkte, die sehr deutlich machen,
dass die Küstenregionen im Grunde Angler unbedingt braucht, weil die sehr sehr viel Geld hier lassen.
Wir wollen also Angler möglichst wenig behindern in ihrer Ausübung,
andererseits müssen die Angler bei einem kollabierten Bestanden ihren Beitrag leisten.
Und auch da sind wir wieder dabei, dass wir sagen, welche Maßnahmen sind durchsetzbar,
also auch kontrollierbar, aber auch welche Maßnahmen sind akzeptabel für die Angelfischerei,
denn wir wollen die ja nicht abschrecken.
Und da fing es dann an, dass wir das systematisiert haben und inzwischen merken wir,
dass die Ergebnisse hoch spannend und wirklich zukunftsweisend sind,
bis wir das am Ende wirklich in die Politik umsetzen können, wird wahrscheinlich noch viel viel Zeit vergehen.
Auch weil das System selber extrem träge ist.
Es gibt halt sehr sehr viele Leute, da wo Entscheidungen getroffen werden
und auch da, wo Regeln kontrolliert werden, die sich nicht vorstellen können,
dass man sowas ganz anders machen könnte.
Erinnert mich auch an ein anderes Gespräch, was wir hier beim Forschergeist schon geführt haben,
auch um Wasserwirtschaft, wo auch die Arbeitsgruppe sehr interdisziplinär aufgestellt wurde,
ganz bewusst auch um, gar nicht mal jetzt nur um – in diesem Fall ist es ja erst mal ein neues Forschungsergebnis,
was dann noch mit einfließt – aber auch sozusagen, um auch die Auswirkungen der eigenen Forderungen
und damit eben sozusagen, wie kommunizieren wir unsere Arbeit auch in die Politik rein,
damit wir die gewünschten Effekte auch erzielen von Ergebnissen, die uns irgendwie total klar vorkommen.
Man fragt sich ja immer, ja warum reagieren die denn nicht?
Weil manchmal ist es ja auch ein Vermittlungsproblem
Ist das vielleicht auch nochmal eine Linie, die sich hier entwickeln kann oder vielleicht schon Teil des Ganzen ist?
Ja das machen wir mehr als learning by doing natürlich seit vielen Jahren.
Wir sind Politikberater.
Wie gesagt, unsere Grundfinanzierung kommt von der Bundesregierung,
vom Landwirtschaftsministerium in diesem Fall und die erwarten von uns guten Rat.
Und natürlich haben wir über viele Jahre daran gefeilt, wie wir den Rat so formulieren können,
dass er beim Empfänger auch ankommt.
Also nichts ist schlimmer, ehrlich gesagt, für einen Politiker, als wenn die Wissenschaftler in typischen Wissenschaftlerkauderwelsch
auf eine klare Frage acht Seiten füllen, wo man am Ende sich durch die acht Seiten geackert hat
und dann sagt, was genau will er mir jetzt eigentlich sagen?
Und wir Wissenschaftler, gerade Grundlagenforscher, kennen das ja auch gut,
dass wir dauernd abwägen.
Also wir stellen die Unsicherheiten in den Vordergrund, das muss man manchmal,
um klarzumachen, verlass dich nicht drauf, dass es genauso kommt.
Wenn wir sagen, ein Bestand erholt sich, dann kann der sich auch schneller,
aber er kann sich auch viel langsamer erholen, Achtung Unsicherheit.
Aber man braucht am Ende irgendeine klare Botschaft.
Und wichtig auf der anderen Seite ist, dass nicht wir die Entscheidungen treffen.
Wir hören von den Umweltverbänden immer wieder, die Fischereipolitik wäre kein Problem,
wenn man die Politik nur verpflichten würde, dem wissenschaftlichen Rat zu folgen.
Dieser Meinung sind wir gar nicht, denn wir liefern bloß Optionen.
Die Entscheidung muss demokratisch legitimiert werden.
Mich wählt keiner, ich bin Bundesbeamter, ich versuche so gut wie möglich
und so verlässlich wie möglich Vorhersagen zu rechnen, und dann der Politik Optionen aufzuzeigen.
Und natürlich habe ich meine eigenen Präferenzen.
Aber am Ende sind es, sagen wir mal, drei Optionen, von denen ich sage,
die wird zu einer schnellen Erholung führen, aber dafür viele Arbeitsplätze kosten.
Dies ist der Mittelweg, dies ist die Option, wo der Bestand möglicherweise 20 Jahre braucht,
aber dafür ist es leichter an die Fischerei zu kommunizieren.
Welchen dieser Wege man geht, bleibt am Ende eine politische Entscheidung und das ist richtig so.
Denn diese Entscheidung kann ich als Biologe nicht fällen.
Und noch schwieriger wird es, wenn wir anfangen, bestimmte Fischarten gegeneinander abzuwägen.
Wir glauben inzwischen, dass wir bei einem sehr einfachen Ökosystem wie der Ostsee,
einfach deswegen, weil es wenig verschiedene Fischereien gibt, die alle an den gleichen Lebensstadien partizipieren,
es gibt wenig genutzte Fischbestände, die einfach miteinander interagieren.
Wir glauben, dass wir das System so einstellen könnten, dass es im Extrem Sprotten- und Herings-dominiert wäre
oder Dorsch-dominiert wäre.
Wir brauchen bloß jemanden, der uns sagt, was er möchte oder irgendwas dazwischen.
Und am Ende gibt es dafür keine biologische Lösung, solange nicht jemand sagt,
wir wollen es auf Protein optimieren oder wir wollen es auf Arbeitsplätze optimieren
oder wir wollen es auf Einkommen der Fischerei optimieren.
Das sind alles berechtigte Zielansätze, die wir nicht gegeneinander abwägen können.
Das haben wir der Politik vorgestellt und haben gesagt, jetzt seid ihr dran,
sagt uns, was wir ihr wollt.
Wir können versuchen, das so einzustellen.
Und die Politik hat abgewunken und gesagt, das geht nicht.
Weil die Skandinavier den größten Anteil an den Herings- und Sprottenfängen in der Ostsee haben
und natürlich sagen, oh ja wir wollen ein Sprotten- und Herings-dominiertes System,
weil wir dann da mehr ernten können.
Und die Deutschen, Dänen und Polen sagen, nein nein wir wollen natürlich ein Dorsch-dominiertes System,
denn das ist ja nun der König der Fische an der Stelle, das ist der Dorsch.
Also warum sollten wir was anderes wollen?
Das ist biologisch nicht lösbar, dafür braucht es einen gesellschaftlichen Konsens
und den können nicht wir Biologen herstellen, sondern dafür brauchen wir am Ende gewählte Politiker.
Und das ist genau richtig so.
Na klar, aber es ist natürlich sinnvoll, wenn man sozusagen auch seine eigene Botschaft schon so austariert hat,
und ich denke, den Politikern wird es natürlich auch entgegenkommen, wenn man sagt,
hör mal, wir haben jetzt hier nicht nur Fische gezählt und irgendwie meeresbiologische Grundlagen erforscht,
sondern wir haben halt hier auch mal so ganz konkret die sozialen Auswirkungen im Bezug auf den Tourismus etc. auch mit abgewogen,
hier ist unsere Gesamtbotschaft, vielleicht passt das ja besser.
Ganz genau, und auch das ist in aller Regel nicht eine Gesamtbotschaft,
sondern es sind eben mindestens zwei oder drei verschiedene Botschaften.
Denn auch da gibt es wieder verschiedene Optionen.
Manchmal sind wir selbst überrascht, was passiert.
Also wir haben uns die Einführung der Tagesfangmengenbegrenzung in der Angelei leichter vorgestellt.
Wir haben offensichtlich nicht genügend auf dem Schirm gehabt, dass die allermeisten Touristen,
die Kutterausfahrten machen, aus Mittel- oder Süddeutschland kommen und sagen,
auch wenn ich in meinem Leben noch nicht mehr als fünf Dorsche gefangen habe,
wenn ich nicht mehr als fünf Dorsche fangen darf, dann komm ich nicht mehr.
Was dazu führt, dass es an der Küste ein großes Kuttersterben gibt und für die kann man keine Beihilfen locker machen,
weil es halt keine Fischereifahrzeuge sind.
Großes Problem, gehen wir jetzt als nächstes an.
Wenn wir Glück haben, erholt sich der Dorschbestand so schnell, dass das keine bleibenden Schäden verursacht.
Aber da gibt es tatsächlich einen Strukturwandel, auf den wir, muss ich ganz selbstkritisch sagen,
die Politik noch besser hätten aufmerksam machen können.
Aber als politikberatende Wissenschaftler genießen wir natürlich einerseits den großen Einfluss,
den wir auf so was wie Gesetzgebung oder Management haben, das ist viel größer
als der Einfluss der Elfenbeinturmforschung, aber wir müssen diese Linie zwischen
wissenschaftlich belegbarem Rat und Meinung ganz ganz klar ziehen
und wir müssen immer darauf achten, dass die Politik das letzte Wort hat.
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel ist die ganze Klimaerwärmungsdebatte und so weiter,
wo wir Wissenschaftler aus meiner Sicht völlig zu recht sehr früh gesagt haben,
Leute tut euch selbst einen Gefallen, mehr als zwei Grad Erwärmung bis so und so ist absolut indiskutabel,
aber wir haben es versäumt, der Politik klarzumachen, was die Folgen einer anderen Entscheidung sind.
Und am Ende hat die Politik fast flächendeckend rausgefunden, das Zwei-Grad-Ziel ist nicht zu halten.
Und dann passiert so was, aus meiner Wahrnehmung wenigstens, passiert so was wie,
die haben gesagt, die Welt geht unter, wenn wir mehr als zwei Grad Erwärmung zulassen,
da wir das nicht halten können, da geht die Welt halt unter, müssen wir uns darum nicht kümmern.
Statt sehr deutlich zu sagen, jedes Viertelgrad macht einen Unterschied.
Und wenn ihr Zweieinhalb Grad macht, dann hat das diese und jene ökonomischen Auswirkungen.
Und da war die Klimadebatte einfach nicht gut genug, und das versuchen wir
in unserem kleinen Bereich zu vermeiden.
Zum Ausklang, auch wenn man damit hätte fast einsteigen können, wollte ich nochmal so ein bisschen auf die Metaebene kommen
und die Frage so, welchen Beitrag sollte und kann das Meer zur Ernährung der Gesellschaft denn überhaupt beitragen?
Das ist natürlich jetzt auch nichts neues und ist auch nicht so ohne weiteres wegzudenken.
Also die Fischstäbchen werden auch weiterhin populär sein.
Aber es stellt sich ja auch immer so diese Frage und es klang ja eben auch schon so an,
so dieses, ist denn dieses Meer für uns beliebig ausbeutbar?
Wie verhält sich das im Gesamtspiel der Nahrungsquellen?
Also das Meer ist natürlich nicht beliebig ausbeutbar, sondern auch die lebenden nachwachsenden Ressourcen des Meeres haben zwar den Vorteil,
dass sie nachwachsen, wenn man sie nachwachsen lässt, aber dafür braucht man ein gutes Management.
Auch dieser Lebensraum ist endlich sozusagen und es bedarf eines guten Managements.
Dass sich das lohnt, davon bin ich fest überzeugt, denn das Meer könnte tatsächlich …
Der Weltozean liefert zurzeit so zwischen 80-100 Millionen Tonnen Ertrag,
zum größten Teil für die menschliche Ernährung, aber nicht ausschließlich.
Und das könnte man um 10-20 Millionen Tonnen steigern diesen Ertrag,
wenn alle Fischbestände in gutem Zustand wären.
Das muss man immer wieder deutlich sagen.
Es lohnt sich, Fischbestände gut zu managen, sie größer werden zu lassen,
weil der Ertrag steigt.
Nun gibt es viele Leute, die einfach jahrelang immer wieder von kollabierenden Fischbeständen gehört haben
und der festen Überzeugung sind, das Meer ist im Grunde leergefischt.
Das Gegenteil ist der Fall.
Es ist tatsächlich so, dass rund 30% der Weltfischbestände, über die wir ausreichend Daten haben,
in schlechtem Zustand sind, also kollabiert oder überfischt oder sich erholend,
auch da gibt es welche darunter und so weiter,
aber der ganze Rest, insbesondere die 58% nach letzten Zahlen, die immer als bis an die Grenze befischt bezeichnet werden,
sind genau in dem Zustand, in dem wir sie haben wollen.
Nach dem UN-Abkommen in Johannesburg wollen wir Fischbestände so managen, dass sie bis an die Grenze befischt werden,
dann werden sie immer noch nachhaltig befischt, aber wir müssen natürlich viel über sie wissen
und wir müssen möglichst vorsichtig sein, damit wir sie nicht über die Grenze in den roten Bereich schieben.
Das Meer ist keineswegs leer gefischt, es gibt viele positive Beispiele dafür,
wie auch stark überfischte oder kollabierte Bestände sich erholt haben.
Keine dieser Meeresfischarten ist vom Aussterben bedroht, weil die Bestandsgrößen viel zu klein werden,
als dass sich eine kommerzielle Fischerei lohnen würde.
Und sie können sich sehr schnell erholen, siehe Beispiel Nordseehering
oder siehe jetzt Beispiel Dorsch der westlichen Ostsee, der im letzten Jahr als kollabiert galt
und wenn alles nur ein bisschen gut geht, dann ist der Anfang 2019 voll im grünen Bereich.
Ein einziger starker Jahrgang reicht am Ende aus, um den Bestand wieder in den grünen Bereich zu bringen,
wenn man rechtzeitig harte Einschnitte vorsieht und das Management entsprechend anpasst.
Und nicht sagt, wird schon nicht so schlimm werden.
Dann kann man auch dafür sorgen, dass so ein Bestand 20-30 Jahre lang sozusagen unter der wirtschaftlich sinnvollen nutzbaren Grenze ist.
Dass sich das lohnt, sieht man auch an der Ostsee.
In der Ostsee geht es fast allen Fischbeständen inzwischen wieder sehr sehr gut,
mit Ausnahme leider der beiden Brotfische der deutschen Fischerei,
dem Hering der westlichen Ostsee und dem Dorsch der westlichen Ostsee.
Das ist sehr sehr unglücklich, aber die allermeisten anderen Bestände sind in sehr gutem oder gutem Zustand.
Die Ostsee kann immer noch das erste vollständig nachhaltige bewirtschaftete Meer der Welt werden.
Und es lohnt sich auch deswegen, weil der Verzehr von wildem Meeresfisch ökologisch vorteilhaft ist.
Er ist einerseits ethisch vorteilhaft, weil diese Tiere, bis zu dem Moment,
wo sie uns ins Netz gingen, ein naturnahes Leben gelebt haben.
Wir haben also all die Probleme mit Massentierhaltung, die wir an Land haben, nicht.
Er ist aber auch ökologisch vorteilhaft, weil die Nahrungsumsetzungsraten von Fisch
extrem günstig sind.
Wenn wir uns angucken, welche food conversion ratios Fische haben,
dann ist es beim Lachs zum Beispiel 2:1.
Also zwei Teile Nahrung brauche ich, um einen Teil für den Menschen verwertbares Lebensmittel zu erzeugen.
Bei Hühnern ist es 3:1, bei Schweinen ist 4:1, bei Rindern ist 8:1.
das heißt, wenn ich das im globalen Zusammenhang sehe und nicht nur aus der Perspektive des Landnutzers,
der sich daran gewöhnt hat, dass wir an Land sowieso alles kaputt machen
und deswegen das Meer möglichst in Ruhe lassen sollen, dann ist es gut mehr Fisch zu essen.
Es wäre natürlich noch besser, mehr Gemüse und Getreide zu essen, keine Frage,
und für jeden vormaligen Fischesser, der durch die Fischführer der Umweltverbände am Ende zum Vegetarier wird,
ist das gut gelaufen, aber wenn ich Fisch substituiere mit Huhn, Schwein oder Rind,
dann habe ich ökologisch nichts gutes getan, im Gegenteil.
Das wäre andersrum besser, eine Rindfleischnahrung durch eine Fischnahrung zu substituieren,
einfach, weil dann mehr für alle übrig ist.
Und wenn wir uns angucken, steigende Weltbevölkerung, Nahrungsmittelknappheit, Proteinversorgung und so weiter,
dann werden wir um Fisch nicht drumrumkommen, es sei denn, es gelingt uns,
die allermeisten Menschen zu 100% Vegetariern zu machen.
Und deswegen mein Plädoyer, das Meer ist ein für den Menschen nutzbarer Raum.
Ich kann verstehen, warum es romantisch überfrachtet ist.
Wir haben an Land so viel kaputt gemacht, aber am Ende müssen wir das Ganze ganzheitlich betrachten
und da werden wir sehr sehr schnell sehen, wir sollten das Meer nutzen,
so nachhaltig, so vorsichtig wie möglich, aber wir sollten nicht einfach die Produktion an Land dafür intensivieren,
damit wir weniger Fisch ernten.
Es gibt natürlich auch solche Trends wie, wie nennt man das, Aqua-Kultur-Farming, gerade im Lachsbereich ist das ja ein Thema.
In einigen Ländern auch ziemlich dramatisch mit entsprechenden Folgen.
Ist das überhaupt in der Ostsee ein Thema?
In der Ostsee ist es kein großes Thema, einfach, weil die, sagen wir mal,
die räumlichen, die morphologischen Gegebenheiten nicht gut sind.
Wenn man ein Land wie Norwegen ist, was überall tiefe geschützte Fjorde hat,
dann eignet sich das für Lachsfarmen besonders gut.
Die Ostsee hat überwiegend flache sandige Küsten, wo man sehr weit raus muss,
um solche Netzkäfiganlagen zu installieren und dann sind sie den offenen Wellen wieder ausgesetzt
und so geschützt, wie wir das eingangs besprochen haben, ist die Ostsee dann doch nicht.
Auch hier versinken großen Fähren einfach wegen Sturmschlag oder sowas.
Also es kann auch hier übel rau zugehen und in Abwesenheit von geschützten Buchten
ist das einfach kein gutes Gebiet für solche Offshore-Farmen.
Das heißt, der Anteil ist relativ gering.
Sind denn Fische, die aus so einem Aqua-Farming hervorgehen dann nicht mehr so Wildtiere
und ist da die Qualität deutlich anders, weiß man da was drüber?
Na die Fische, die aus Aqua-Kulturen kommen, sind keine Wildtiere.
Das muss man ganz klar sagen.
Das Hausschwein, das wir selbst von einem Ökobauern beziehen, ist kein Wildschwein mehr.
Das ist ganz klar.
Also diese Vorteile, der hat sein Leben in Wildnis verbracht, wir haben keinen Einfluss auf seine Ernährung und so weiter,
wir haben keinen Einfluss, wie er sich vermehrt hat, das einzige, was wir tun können, ist,
ihn vorsichtig nutzen, damit der Bestand groß genug bleibt
Diese Vorteile gibt man auf, dafür hat man auf der anderen Seite den Vorteil,
dass man die Produktion zum Beispiel fast beliebig steigern kann.
Wie in der Massentierhaltung üblich.
Man hat also die gleichen Probleme, die wir in der Massentierhaltung an Land haben,
hat man auch, die kann man alle adressieren.
Und es gibt viele kluge Köpfe, ich bin nun kein Aqua-Kultur-Forscher,
aber es gibt viele kluge Köpfe, die sich Gedanken machen, wie man den Antibiotikaeinsatz immer weiter reduzieren kann,
zum Beispiel wie man die Haltungsdichten so macht, dass es auch tierfreundlich ist.
Wie man mit den Fäkalien aus diesen Anlagen umgeht, wie man verhindert,
dass es Escapees gibt, also hochgezüchtete, auf Produktion gezüchtet Lachse gibt,
die dann ausbrechen und sich mit den Wildbeständen vermischen und die schwächen,
einfach weil sie schneller wachsen, und deswegen einen Fortpflanzungserfolg haben,
Das kann man alles adressieren, da gibt es viele erfolgreiche Ansätze,
aber es sind halt völlig andere Probleme, als die, die wir haben, wenn wir Wildfisch nutzen.
Das sind alles Sachen, die wir uns im Wildfischbereich überhaupt nicht angucken müssen.
Aber es klingt ja schon jetzt so ein bisschen, als wäre tendenziell zumindest diese Aqua-Kultur-Technik eher eine zweifelhafte Maßnahme?
Nein finde ich gar nicht.
Also ich glaube, wenn wir uns um Welternährung kümmern und nochmal im Hinterkopf haben,
dass die Nahrungsumsetzraten bei Fisch günstiger sind als bei den allermeisten anderen Tieren,
die wir so in der Landzucht haben, dann lohnt es sich viel mehr zu investieren,
auch in die Fischzucht.
Denn das wird aus Wildfischbeständen nicht alles ausreichend kommen können.
Selbst wenn wir sagen, die Wildfischbestände könnten, wenn sie alle in gutem Zustand sind,
20 Millionen Tonnen mehr Ertrag pro Jahr liefern, wird das nicht reichen.
Das heißt, wir werden uns Gedanken machen müssen über Aqua-Kultur, die dauernd wächst und wächst und wächst
und ich glaube inzwischen bei 40 oder 50% der Gesamtfischproduktion der Welt ist.
Also Wildfischerei ist schon nur noch 50%.
Das wird auch weiter wachsen, bin ich ziemlich überzeugt davon, aber man muss sich eben dann sehr sorgfältig andere Probleme angucken,
und dann lohnt es sich vielleicht, auf Bioproduktion zu gehen und so weiter.
Aber auch da nochmal, in einem norwegischen Zuchtlachs sind heute schon weniger Antibiotika
als selbst in einem Ökorind, muss man einfach wissen.
Die Land- und die Wasserproduktion ist da sehr sehr unterschiedlich.
Ja und vor allem die Bodenlandwirtschaft beeinflusst ja das Meer und durch Nährstoffe, die eingetragen werden aus der Landwirtschaft,
also Düngemittel etc., andersrum ist das ja eher nicht so.
Ganz genau. Das Meer hat ein relativ, außer über Klima jetzt natürlich, einen relativ geringen Einfluss auf die terrestrischen Ökosysteme.
Andersrum wissen wir als spätestens seit letztem Jahr, dass auch die Überdüngung einen wesentlichen Einfluss darauf hat,
dass der Nachwuchs des Herings der westlichen Ostsee immer weniger wird.
Das ist ein Zusammenspiel aus Temperaturerwärmung in weiten Teilen der westlichen Ostsee
und Nährstoffeintrag.
Und an der Stelle wird es jetzt echt spannend, wie man das denn eigentlich abwägt.
Wir leben hier in einem Land, Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, was stolz auf eine florierende Landwirtschaft ist,
aber auch stolz auf den Tourismus und stolz auch auf die Fischerei ist.
Und an der Stelle muss man jetzt anfangen abzuwägen, könnte man verhindern,
dass so viele Nährstoffe, also vor allen Dingen Phosphate und Nitrate in die Küstengewässer eingetragen werden,
indem man breitere Uferstreifen an den Flüssen oder so was nutzungsfrei oder wenigstens düngemittelfrei lässt,
was dann möglicherweise wieder eine sehr positive Auswirkung auf die Entwicklung des Heringsbestandes hat.
Denn unsere Heringsfischer knapsen zurzeit durch den immer kleiner werdenden Bestand.
Und es ist nicht deren Schuld, sondern es ist sozusagen die Schuld der geänderten Umweltbedingungen und der Überdüngung.
Sie sagten vorhin, die Ostsee kann vielleicht das erste nachhaltig bewirtschaftete Ökosystem oder Meeresökosystem werden,
ist das sozusagen das Ziel, ist das ein weit ausgerufenes oder eher ein privates Ziel von Ihnen?
Na das ist mehr meine Vorhersage, um auch zu sagen, wir sind auf einem guten Weg dahin.
Wir sind gar nicht mehr so weit weg.
Wir haben in der Ostsee andere Probleme, menschengemachte Probleme, die auch bleiben werden.
Wenn wir so was wie Munitionsverklappung und seit vielen vielen Jahren weiß man,
dass die Dinger vor sich hin rotten, jetzt sind sie endlich so weit, dass sie Munitionsbestandteile freisetzen,
die dann natürlich auch irgendwie giftig sind.
Das ist alles auf relativ kleiner Skala, ist nicht so, dass man den Fisch nicht mehr essen kann.
Aber ich frage mich schon, wieso wartet man denn eigentlich 20 Jahre wissend, dass man sie jetzt noch händeln kann
und in 20 Jahren kann man sie nicht mehr händeln, weil die Granaten oder was weiß ich alle zerfallen.
Wir haben nach wie vor in der nördlichen Ostsee die Belastung mit Schwermetallen und auch mit DDT-Derivaten,
also irgendwie persistenten chlororganischen Stoffen und so weiter.
Die da vermutlich auch nie wieder rausgehen, wegen der tiefen Beckenstruktur.
Die werden einfach dauernd rezykliert und dann gelangen sie wieder in die Wassersäule und dann sinken sie wieder zu Boden und so weiter.
Solche Probleme können wir erst mal nicht lösen, aber die Probleme mit der Überfischung können wir lösen.
Und wir sind da auf einem sehr sehr guten Weg und deswegen aus Fischsicht,
nur darauf war das bezogen, denn andere Sachen haben wir nicht in der Hand,
kann es tatsächlich sein, dass in Europa die Ostsee das erste Gebiet ist,
in der keine einzige Fischart, kein einziger Fischbestand mehr überfischt ist.
Da wollen wir gerne hin.
Dann wünsche ich Ihnen da noch viel Erfolg auf diesem Weg.
Und bedanke mich für das ausführliche Gespräch über die Fischerei in der Ostsee.
Und auch darüber hinaus und das hat ein paar interessante Einblicke gegeben.
Mir und sicherlich auch allen, die hier zugehört habe, also vielen Dank.
Sehr gerne.
Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist.
Uns gibt es dann auch bald wieder, wie immer.
Ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.